right and we are live welcome to the
iron Lords podcast episode number 90 and
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
extremely excited about our special
guests and we've got all the latest
drama regarding Fallout 76 game award
leaks Nintendo stream policy changes and
the Xbox one X revenue to discuss so we
gonna get right into it we're gonna talk
about that fallout 76 game of the year
not only a great friend to the road but
is also a fellow Lord of the arcade
although this Lord is extremely
outspoken and a strong opinions may rub
some the wrong way this Lord is always
invites healthy and respectful debate
with the sole focus of doing what's
right by the gaming community
introducing that created host of the
basement arcade radio podcast the media
bias and console fanboy destroyer on
Twitter and the Lord with the best
batman impersonation you'll ever find in
the Best Buy parking lot making his
return into the realm of the Lords mommy
Lord brat podcast
how you doing sir whoo I'm here with the
full horseman of gaming baby oh you know
what what you just stole right there was
the my fraud alert because there was
some people that was running around here
acting like they're the four horsemen
and a full Horseman reside here so I
want you to understand I'm the first one
in I'm the last one out I'm war so
anytime you call war that's what you
won't get joined uh you don't well you
do leave to you usually first man
know what I can say about that yesterday
thanks for coming over man it's a
pleasure to have you back it's been a
minute man how are you doing sir I am
doing very well it's been yeah man it's
been a long time man since I've been on
last and I'm happy that you all were
kind enough to vite you back to the
realm and man I'm just happy to be here
and ready to talk some videogames and
you never go no Adele bad absolutely man
had to do it you know saying Lord in
your realm we love what brat podcast is
doing totally right and bring you back
show you that proper respect from our
day ones man so we don't get into it and
you know we have the original Four
Horsemen of gaming those Lords of the
realm here at the aren't aren't table my
co-host with the call most my brother
from another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the house of the young
wolf mommy
Lord Attica doing sir pretty good
playing a I'm gonna call this Pokemon
0.5 because I'm not even gay oh come on
status but you know I'm having a pretty
good morning or still half asleep so
because it is 11 a.m. I said what are we
going back to one man that's what I want
to know you got two more weeks
literally the next at the Nexus for the
love it for the day they're the Lords of
putting up with me right now in two more
weeks we go back so I know and one
o'clock won't be at least will return
thank you be as life may about it
[Music]
it's a sovereign the only one that don't
work at night because we work during the
night your mic holds up whole podcast we
would like to have you for a whole pot
Wow
but that's bugbear that up miss we have
our most technical gaming Lord the solo
game homeless for the single player
selfish experience
and also the sastra darkness mr. offline
profile Illuminati and Lord patreon of
the iron baked mommy
Lord sovereign are you doing sir I'm
doing good man doing alright
I uh considering the week I've had it's
I'm good it's gone glad to be here you
know I some up and downs this week uh
had to put my grandfather in hospice
care and uh than that yeah that was
that's never an easy thing and it's like
if you're from New York and particularly
the Bronx like you hear the name cavalry
hospital you know that that's a fact
fact especially coming from New York
Ortiz Hospital whatever hear that I'll
be funeral stuff yeah so that you know
that that's very tough that's very tough
um and then on a brighter note Friday
was my five year anniversary so shout
out to my much much much much much
better half
amazing yeah we went out for dinner we
went to uh she took me out to to my
favorite spot brother for the week mall
we got me in the mood yeah we got the
meat in the meat on and we did you did
you get the Leblon drink than I did of
course he got to a boil but no how do I
go I got the LeBron oh and they had
extra stuff this time like crazy they
had some octopus salad they went for
they had a new hoping meal around the
Addison some holiday stuff that's what's
up yo shout out to the chair j-dub on
everybody's in it saying the cat daddy
say praise the thank you God
you got shot that's that's very brief
dinner I had been faking around forever
for a week four weeks already I told her
that we were I was taking it to a show
so she hoping that it was Lion King but
I was faking her out completely right so
at dinner she asked me one last time
like is it Lion King and I yo I put on
the straightest most disgusted face like
right and I looked at us a babe like if
that's what you're expecting I'm sorry
you're gonna be really disappointed like
I was one of those like out like you
played a good I'm taking detours did not
go right down the block
come on get to the front didn't go in
this you starts to cry this is some
little girl and you know this is like a
20 year old show at this point yeah it
is a magical thing to see and you know
how I do when I do it I do it so we were
we were no front row was taking so I got
second row all right so she was right
there when animals walks like a that's
what's up good congratulate anniversary
some shout out the lady soft putting up
with all the podcast foolishness that we
could no doubt about and we will be
taking care of business later sir yes we
will okay no doubt yeah
and of course we have the Incredible
Hulk of this aka
the XS gamer copy as soon as you're part
they welcome the Lord of galvez sports
it was aware of his convictions the way
is nothing less than the premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert more
mate Oh be loving Lord King are you
doing said you know exactly how the hell
I'm doing I'm doing like Deontay Wilder
last night well an hour all people I'm
gonna go get something to drink I'll be
overseas yeah it's nothing like a
heavyweight fight in America there's
nothing like a champion are going up
against another worthy champion it's
nothing like it it's like the
electricity in the rule was magical it
was bananas it was so incredible that
you you felt it you felt it right so um
I'm not gonna get too much into exactly
what went on you look at the combats
from you know is up there so check that
out but two fighters live in a moment
you saw Tyson Fury walk to the ring and
I don't care what nobody say that
brother was living his truth making out
that door he was living his truth he
didn't care who was looking at him it
was like he was the lone by his self
singing his favorite songs going to the
ring because he he reached his
mountaintop he was at the depths of
despair and he clawed his way back to
respectability and got in that ring and
showed exactly what a champion is
supposed to do been the real champ
walked out and the real champ walked out
like the champ supposed to come out
because when you saw Tyson come on did
you champ win fight was fine before you
start kick I just wanna say I did not
watch it right what watching Twitter and
seeing the reactions of everybody I was
like I felt like boxing was alive for a
couple out like if it took me back to
like you know yeah Phil Tyson day
whatever was going on it felt that so
Brigid then I remember
not out to that whole car that whole
card felt like an earth part of
everything it was a Showtime they
listened al Haman hmm
I've been in need you brother thanks for
doing the things that you were able to
do in this 2018 and at the level where
every fight that they produce was a
must-see fighter Lipton's and every
expectation and to cap it off with this
fight to cap it off with this this is
like a cherry on the top the whipped
cream and everything of miracles this
was so good that the drama going into
the 12th round then the champion you
felt needed a knockout
you needed to do something to show
something this dude hit him with the
boat of Zeus I'm telling you he hit him
with the bolt Azusa cracked on with the
hammer throw with the left hook for good
measure this is nobody on this planet
that we got a his do got up like the
Undertaker you think means what we was
talking the whole time like the whole
time we talk I'm talking we've we j-dub
we talking I'm talking with everybody
that can actually talk with let me tell
you I've never seen nothing like that in
my life
I've never seen anything like that that
that Tyson Fury getting up like that yo
the position got knocked out was like a
crime scene
yo got you saw it was kind of sped up
you all right because when he got hit he
laid there like he was dead I thought he
died
Paulie Malignaggi because he pointed
this out in his two most rests would not
have even counted cake cake said the
cocaine kicked in that's like
he was out use out his eyes was closed
and then it said yo lady popped up to
his body
listen know what first of all the same
he can't like the game over screen yet
cocaine from hitman allegedly allegedly
alright I want to say allegedly first of
all I don't want to discredit this man
for his heart and his tenacious his his
Fuhrer to get into that ring back give
everything that he had cuz he left
everything near both of those men did
and any point in time both of those men
could have packed at him but they didn't
they both they both hugged and embraced
at the end of the fight respect but I'm
going to tell you this here we go and
and I'm gonna say this and I want y'all
to investigate it on your own mmm-hmm
why the hell was Freddie Roach in this
man's corner he never trained this man
ever day in his life in this fight Tyson
Fury had energy from a man who had four
there was 400 pounds got down to 265
pounds he had energy from round one to
round twelve he looked like the same
dude for round one to round twelve Wow
and we yeah it's impressive
at the same time early Manny Pacquiao
you still look the same way with Freddie
Roach oh I know I know are you going but
I I hope I hope I hope to god he don't
come back
his urine is dirty I hope to god it
doesn't I hope you got the Panama Lewis
special it's tea I want to step back
from it and just say I hope not because
it was a magical night and any deserve
to end when I draw and I want y'all to
go look at the combat talk to figure out
and I'm and I gave you round by round
and I explained how a boxing actually
works how does glory system works and
and what it means when you have two
heavyweights of that magnitude and the
Motors this involved so just go check
that out and talk and and we can debate
about it I don't I don't care
um I don't I really had a dog in a fight
because I really wanted this young man
to win and continue to his growth
because he started boxing at a very late
age become a bronze medal champion in
Olympics
that is beautiful so oh boy a fury on
them Senzu beans King no Kuni that's
what's up of course we have the gaming
engine himself this shinobi Lord kognito
spreading that realness in the realm of
the ILP and I'll tell you what you want
to hear but what you need to hit so yeah
Matt for me has been my glorious
glorious master race pc debut said that
your destiny to versa addict
Oh get your bro 1080p a cat frame Oh two
settings everything closed field of view
and I got my Xbox elite controller
control the game for life y'all beg beg
so yeah man I've been rocking it
hardcore
shout out the deaf sing in the chat baby
I've seen um I picked up the XCOM
tactical pack which currently right now
is PC exclusive yes undead it's been
very glorious thank you oh yeah man
speed the resolution like I was telling
a dick offline they have like narrative
basically they have throwback missions
King to XCOM like when we first played
the first ones yeah and you're playing
as the guy that's always obstructing you
like commander that guy like back when
he were or it went left and you're out
in the field and it's being narrated
while you play it feels like a oh you
get it it's pretty much like the time
frame right after they blew up the alien
home base up into the second one yeah
and it's just though it feels like a
Vietnam setting and they're losing
people and you get to play as him you've
got that they've got these different
challenge modes
picked it up on a good Steam sale so I
was doing that
um state of decay tube shout-out to
fogey in the cruel man Louis Yepez in
the crew arm said hunter I played that
on PC just to test xbox play anyway
let me tell you something right now fill
in it yo let me tell you not only was
Brad not only was it's so easy to
transferred everything I did on Xbox my
achievements where I was my data I
didn't miss a beat and to be able to go
back and forth you know I'm saying like
oh man it's the future and now it's like
I get it from a fanboys perspective like
all the exclusive or not bro it's more
options man now I'm a PC gamer I don't
feel separate from my xbox
I can literally still just continue
doing what I'm doing so ah yeah man I'm
an extra question cognero you know for
because we were on Comcast yesterday you
know a lot of guys had day panties in a
bunch
no isn't I get dangerous I'm dangerous
so um that you know a lot of dudes had a
panties in a bunch
about Microsoft being able to play in a
PC arena and what I explained was that
they pedigree was from there so you know
cutting that off was [ __ ] in the
sense that why limit yourself when
you've had these options and the fact
that you got a chance to test these
options out man named Phil that is
that's a good Avenue for them and [ __ ]
because somebody in the podcast
yesterday said they should have been
doing that decades ago mmm interesting
but a whole my opinion on first of all
it is fantastic the feature is seamless
you know if they the only complaint I
would say is like the xbox act could be
a little updating a little bit better I
mean that update in a sense that um like
how discord and other things kind of
play in the background I would like to
play in the background so achievements
and I mean like I could party chat you
can party try to do I just want the app
to stay active in the background so to
speak oh it does not that it does it
it's just that you know I'm saying like
usually during your game your focus in
your game you know kind of thing but I
love it to get it it's just seamless if
there's no no dinner I said my cup head
and stuff and I've done that that's the
only reason why I'm accent because I
as anybody that was on the panel that
yeah you know like all the stuff they're
gone I talked to I talked to other
people going I want to play party chat
every party chat everything's there my
chief mints there that's the big day
like for the achievement hunters you
know when you go to PC that I always
felt like yeah you plan on PC it don't
mean that because you ain't really
getting them achievement like you know
achievements that you know it's adding
to your score so it's like it's just a
good thing it's more options there's
nothing if you don't like PC you don't
have to play PC you don't like Xbox get
PC they what you did so it is really is
it's a win-win for Microsoft it's just
more of a fanboy foolish option then you
know they feel away about stuff but
that's just me that's how I feel like
that but shout out to all discord this
man I don't know how to hell y'all PC
game is playing without this court yo
that's the Xbox the Xbox Live it is
really lit you know I'm says so that's a
geeky nerd says the option is nice but
it sort of limits the console install
base in my opinion think about making
the money they bout making money on
software man that's what they want to do
they want to make that money on software
that's how I feel but anyway that's all
I got is pretty much what I've been
doing so all a little actually lower
solve do you want to jump in and then
I'll do my announcement after your
announcement okay okay what announcement
are you making alright now it's my army
meetings I got some new waves new waves
to announce oh it's right all right so
as Patriots on baby let's go let's go
say it avails babies pay the bills
thankful um so let's start with our
patreon thank you thank you so much guys
obviously when you say this every month
but we appreciate everything you guys do
for us so let's start with a shout outs
I'm gonna start out with Lord Korey lied
dick woo
whiskey thank you very much my brother
PlayStation brah thank you what my
friend thank you so much Lord cream h
AKA QX seven masters thank you so much
beautiful oh no we know that's a
dictation on I like the games so Luke
welcome to the rap welcome to the room
Lord Chris Williams aka Fastback
that's the hole
you shouted to the Mustang Lord of
Mustangs Lord of Mustang thank you so
much man Lord I'm ed Hernandez sounds
like a wrestler name thank you please no
its new name so this patriot
thank you God has a pretty deep support
know the Lord of not backing Pat anymore
the lord of project x the cloud cloud
Lord bills still well thank you much
appreciated
Lord Ricky Moore jr. aka Lord to's thank
you so much for the support man though
he's new - I think he's not he's fairly
new yeah he's only been here a couple of
weeks a month so thank you so much the
original patreon subscriber himself
Michael Lugo monkey polish thank you
mama punchy was first in a chat today
400 a saloon
punch is amazing you know followed by
Lord spoon man thank you hard baby cried
about loves ya o goes hard goes off I'll
peek salute that's cool man see him in a
chat much appreciate you sir
and a big shout-out to our friend Jay
Fonzarelli thank you so much my brother
out of funds that's not that's a hole
that's been what could you say that's
bad about the father and the Godfather
of the stream team himself Lord snout Oh
Peter
is it a chase a keep taking our buddy
the stream team leader that's our guy
right there right here family from the
cradle to the grave Lord loaded pixels
himself Cobra thank you so much my
brother mm-hmm oh it's the man with
every single iron Lord t-shirt ever
created Lord cat daddy fat stacks look
at daddy who put us out of business man
we got enough shirt bugs
course our brother from over the disease
Lord death singer Thank You
death I hope you got your shirt already
one thing I did not realize about
teespring is that to bring only ships on
certain schedules so yes I placed an
order and there's no guaranteed shipping
out soon so
I hope you got your shirt already let's
do it
and then last but not least of course
Lord optimist coat thank you so we gotta
get cold back man yeah coat is amazing
so many gems when he came on man saluted
called master og veteran and his
technical acumen is is really second and
I need that the Lord knows gaming salute
there man so what else - gasps oh we got
we got some other big things you got to
do our regular free stuff monthly and
and bimonthly stuff I just letting you
guys know act come January there gonna
be some changes to the patreon and
certain things that we do but I'll talk
about that stuff in January generally in
general but um for right now yeah we
have our regular monthly giveaways and
it also time for our bimonthly giveaway
so we'll be giving a weird game today
woo yeah yeah we you you kill in our
pockets today the I'm banking empty
today so let's start out with this a $10
gift card giveaway so we're gonna start
this oh and you know a beep oh and I'm
gonna sound when I do yeah yeah it
bothers dudes I'll do the sound sound
you gotta do Sam loaded pixels Oh
go bury yet one well Aaron got a new
good number generator this time song
like that it all seemed fraudulent Oh
seemed like the grease your palm so now
the $20 gift card the winner of the $20
gift card is I don't think I pay
attention nobody more - oh no yo you got
a new number trader in a son no these
are real winners today fire collusion
kick we all be gonna accuse anyone
so now the winner of our t-shirt
giveaway and what we're doing with the
t-shirt stuff now is that basically if
you want you can get it off of T spring
so it'll be a t-shirt or anything under
the price of a t-shirt so sorry guys no
hoodies those hoodies are kind of yeah
you can get a t-shirt you can get a
monster with his comment Beta Beta Beta
text teespring giveaway let's call it
that Ricky Moore again yo Ricky so some
look at Ricky cuz we told y'all last
month y'all gotta get in this patreon so
more people could win and Ricky got in
that Pedro Wow drum roll either he said
is that a drum roll or Chewbacca damn
you and you see Tommy said those hoodies
are made out of good but to salute
that's what I'm trying to tell everybody
G Premium hoodie canvas material is that
still there we go last but not obviously
not least the winner of our bi-monthly
game give away okay just a big one a big
one of the big ones last cool Lord noted
pixels yet hockey Coco bear oh man
that's a big one
shouted Jonathan B's hair he said
collusion gang what's up we handed out
free yes we are yes we are but that is
not all ladies and gents not a big one
today marks the conclusion of our Super
Smash Brothers gleam giveaway mmm thank
you too Lord Snell doe for managing the
dealing dishing out the banhammer when
necessary when we we have BOTS trying to
win things not a fraudulent Lord's China
we gotta win something for the people
King has made a very apparent I'm all
about the free ship okay no said it's
the big one it's the big one it is my
pleasure to announce that the winner of
the Super Smash Brothers gleam giveaway
is Lord Michael deferent aka King Mike
too
8:24 okay gratulations not gonna be the
game sharing it yeah oh just game share
with him up to Michael deferent um I
will be contacting you after the show
with all the info getting new your code
so you can be ready for next week when
the game officially drops and 18 very
very soon we will be dropping our next
game giveaway I'm not gonna say what the
game is just yet but I'll leave it at
that so stay tuned for that then you go
slow salute Louis our page you're on the
iron bank and if you see right now you
know say I'm trying to drop in some
links in the chat the chat will get the
exclusive right now the new flavors
y'all the new ways I don't know why I'm
the only face I believe everybody got a
camera I mean my drawers do and nobody
need to say you know what that's justice
that's exactly what I don't like about
you youtubers y'all say y'all y'all are
not given the respect due to these
people that is up listening they want to
see you they want every room listen I
can't I can't trust me
the beard for you I sort of chapstick
gold right they were carrying an
underwear talk we kind of is shoveled
right now bro t-shirt shorts IOP shirt
I'm a rock therefore you notice I put
those links in the chat the original
Four Horsemen of gaming cometh it is now
available on the ILP store so rep your
favorite Lords all the lords ever ever
would you want to be the XS gamer you
know say you're gonna be the size to
Dallas you know say what you want to be
the difficult game Kocher the gaming
ninja it is up it's finally here please
check those out cop those if you like
man we got some more stuff coming but oh
yeah man it is up definitely requesting
so uh that's what we got minute so it's
off are you good on your side I been
good
I'm Frankie's good I'm Bank is my
pockets are very thin thank you very
much the Greenes thing will not go down
this month
what t-shirts is up right so if you're
looking at your chat right now right
logos that's up right there like our
avatars like addicts avatar which is
mrs. hot in sovereigns and avatars
beside no cockney nose isn't up right
now because you know he's representative
of the realm and so but his is hot too
this is mine right here so um like I
said that's the four horsemen
you know resonating so links up man
check that out like I said the four
horsemen of gaming that is up so now
that we got the business out of the way
with the iron bank and Lord Brad has
already been giving the aisle peak oil
treatment in the past or please check
Aisle P number 26 for his incredible
video game system history but I realized
something long rap not it was a change
off format mmm
no need Lord Bratz top five gay French
of all time we definitely or the spot
baby let's go spit them bars
oh man who says like like being on a
show and having live like freestyle or
something oh yes yes that's what I feel
like now like I'm like I'm um I wanted a
spotlight what you got
you know I punished by death
I mean I'll say Zelda's up there as
where is the top franchise oh my god man
there's so many franchises and come off
Red Dead two keys man I mean it's tough
what about what about what about games
that affected you they may not even be
here you don't say nothing to be
critically came it's just something that
had an importance in your life as a game
I'll say Zelda without a doubt I'm gonna
sell the franchise no no you guys
remember the graph paper making man
that's that's old-school and yets and
that's what we did man that's you know I
got the NES classic mmm watch my four
years of fire up Zelda I'm just like yo
that was me yes that was me back in the
days you know I'll say dad that's one
final fantasy okay okay the Final
Fantasy series okay Metal Gear Metal
Gear Solid like a wild moment for me
yes did you know that's that's like the
first time we had like this fully
immersive like world like you know I
mean like it's just because there's a
Dali technology and a change from the
previous generation of that generation
yeah and you know it's funny he's funny
sitting for me that the particular one
for me was the he was it to PlayStation
2 one whether they gave us a demo we're
going like a boat
and they tell you no Milo you fought for
Psycho Mantis and he said put the
controller down he made it move
yes that was my moment I was
yeah like it's so so many different
iconic moments that I feel like Metal
Gear doesn't get enough credit for I'm
with you on that Brett yeah um you know
jeez man
guys you halo halo did for console
first-person shooters just it put it on
the map I mean really did yes I mean you
were you weren't playing first-person
shooters for the most part on console at
the time it was just like twitch right
changed the game for console gamers to
join the FPS space I definitely do with
you yeah um you know I gotta get Mario
man a shout out because I mean Mario is
a phrase one of those franchises that
Odyssey was like wow like they'd still
like like Mars been around for what 40
years to be your boss bones you had
trouble for them for your jokes on
Jasper Johns you become beach-volleyball
change his life as a kid you know that
was actually a decent volleyball game oh
it wasn't bad okay
I can't think he won't stop my head that
you play exactly know why cuz it didn't
had a purse but we remember the ping
pong game that came out for the Xbox
feels like one of the greatest games
y'all
ping-pong is especially little moments
that if it stands out the gameplay was
there I mean I know the other stuff
there Rob cat daddy say nobody was
checking for the ball physics Lord rap I
beg thankfully that 11 was not on your
list it was it's a it's a closed pod
Allah you gotta love the work team
engineering top of the game man need to
mortar manse is tough uh you know I want
to I was thinking about Konami the other
day mmm as a developer and where they've
come and gone pretty much gone
Castlevania whoa whoa I mean that game
it's funny I see my son playing and he
has classic that game is just like wow
me was difficult it inspired you know I
so many other games that we would come
to love later on the future that's
that's a franchise I've been watching
the Netflix series yeah
I want another Castlevania game back
that that's a series that Konami needs
to bring back the fans demanded hey Bret
some extra question are you sick and
tired of what the Metroid style of
because look like me to say this I think
it was like two ok years ago that he
wants a full like 3d um you know or
Castlevania yeah that's all I'm gonna I
want to know like which kind of
Castlevania do you want do you want the
Metroid style that we got now that's
that they keep permeating us with or
would you like a new like 3d no I want a
new 3d I mean like like even like if
they took like I look at like
Castlevania the Netflix series even if
it was like visually like like that
mm-hmm
in a 3d where I would be okay with that
yeah yeah just an imagining of the
franchise because I mean we've got the
Metro vania is so good and then king of
that you know I'm not trying to take
anything away from that it's just that
it's kind of like they need almost like
a God of War moment for me I think
that's a jewel guys over to say okay
what is the whole law behind it cuz now
you've got a lot of new god of war
fiends loving God would never really
knew about the other the other stuff so
that's just how I feel about him but um
man it's classic franchise that's a good
one gone that is it is that it just you
gotta remember it influenced so many
other games like we talked about the
metroidvania type of games that are out
now and you see a lot of Indies kind of
paying you know paying their homage to
you know that error in that kind of
style of gameplay so um last one
any generation doesn't have to be recent
any deeper
come on spit them verses but you know
let it go I'm gonna go with I'm gonna go
with uh gazing especially this console
gen it's like wow you know what's that
Snoopy's adventures yeah I thought I
thought attics hitbox adventures I'm
gonna go with The Witcher Lord negative
says the controls are worse you know
because he's a Souls Fannie's everything
the souls you know he's on that Souls
hierarchy when I like to call the soul
snobs
yeah because nevermind we already
I'll be the first term in the combat is
not as good as sold but mm-hmm
but the overall game is just the
storytelling the characters I mean it's
just it's just that was just don't get
how we could just skip the fact that it
plays like you're a wrong like I don't
get that like it's like Oh everything
else is good but but the thing that we
do that's not good but it's people just
keep like walking along on the fact that
the game is the worst fighting styles
based on fencing I mean if you go back
to you know the books and he's it's what
his styles and I think the truck they're
trying as best they can to mimic that
style of fencing and so it doesn't it
probably doesn't translate the best but
everything else is just just amazing
about that game and so I'm okay with
maybe the combat not being as good
you'll even Assassin's Creed Odyssey
like combat isn't that great in that
game mm-hm but there's so many other
great things about that game
well you're not thinking oh my god man
this combat could be better I don't
think there will ever be a time where I
won't complain about combat
you know the gameplay of the game I'll
walk up to someone you know I might say
something about you know with the faces
off of Mass Effect Andromeda because you
know that that's just an appearance of
something else but it's not gonna get to
the poor of like you know what I'm gonna
overlook like 80% of the game chested
don't get attic started out is the
combat isn't so bad that it's like that
it takes away from the other parts of
the game you know Dobrev Bobo's lady
said neighbor Rockstar game that doesn't
feel like [ __ ] oh I'm dead
your day I'd say what the top five is so
hard I've been doing this a long time
and not play I mean I this this year to
me this year has probably been one of
the best years in gaming that I can
remember
that's wow
leave bushes boy alone
like bread thank you for it for taking
that freestyle on this spot top 5 I
respect it was meaning to do it you
could obviously I can say we had changed
the format we never got that for them so
now that he's back we got that all
signed and delivered so we gonna get
into last week's Pulver's right people
are gonna start calling me the from
software so now thank you for that
thanks Paul results are in and the
people have spoken
to the question with the MPD sales
success of black ops for removing a
traditional single-player campaign in
favor for multiplayer centric modes how
concerned are we that other titles of
the same vein follow suit with this
practice the winner at 44% was the not
concern CEO D is an anomaly 2018 as
proven single player is here and stay
group at second place at 37% was the
very concerned publishers have the
analytics and when a mimic similar
profit success group and in last place
at 19% was the I don't care it was all
fun and games until CEO D stole battle
royal mode all the lords who
participated in last week's O Lord
brap what do you feel about this man do
you feel that uh you agree with the
people that uh C call duty was an
anomaly net just because they got rid of
single player that it still single
player still here to stay yeah a single
players not going anywhere it might be
going it might be gone with with black
ops specifically black ops I don't see
the other call to be franchises
abandoning single player just yet I
could be wrong though but a single place
without anyone here mmm-hmm would you
say that it I said wait till next year
yes that's a great point wait to make
Chevy I just I'm just saying I the I
just think I I don't see it going
anywhere with other but I could another
all call duties but I could be wrong I
mean like at excited wait they may they
may show up at e3 with uh you know Call
of Duty you know they they they world
war ii mean i don't know what they're do
next
this has the marketer rights oh yeah in
the bushes like oh
rumored uh you know February event
that's only supposed to have maybe
rumored I say roomie of you are highly
doubt ecology D the next one will be
announced there that's why you say so
for Sony joke like it really is like
they have a lot of marketing does and
stuff for them just to skip out on III
you gotta see was gonna have a best so
shout to all the lords who participate
in the poll new one will be cooking up
at the end of the show we're gonna get
into these topics Shaw so well I'm gonna
jump off first and um I'll be full
disclosure and I'm saying we obviously
talked about fallout 76 but um gotta be
honest y'all I did not want to cover
this topic in the realm initially most I
do haha I know you do
most of all my peers and you know
multiple to the news outlets we've
already covered this and it just it just
got to the point though with so much
additional information to keep pouring
in the Lord's have to talk about the
fraud what do you mean fraud addicts
been here now obviously we haven't
talked about it and I want to approach
this definitely I first of all shout out
to load anchorman he answered the Batman
call the signal is up for the air but
that's the signal is up you're the first
person I've ever seen a willing to come
to their own death all people with your
bets are one to talk concerned about the
condition of his
we're gonna do five talking points and
we're also gonna be respectful of Lord
anchorman we know pretty much his
position and we feel your dog's position
we figured oh okay good dog we may fake
his opinions but he may surprise so
here's the five topics where we gonna
focus on Lord breath it's gonna be one
the state of the game specifically we
know Lord Jason Schreyer his uh
terminology in reference to game engine
and was that acceptable at launch point
to canvas bag gate was this a
bait-and-switch by Bethesda then we're
gonna go point three I don't know if any
of you guys know where this just
happened but as a recent homophobic
grieving scandal yeah I'll break it down
we get the yeah I'll break it down put
the link in the chat so basically I want
to discuss because of what happened the
current grieving and reporting system in
the game so we will do that briefing
grief free thing yeah obviously use it
grieving I'm like yeah let me give you
chat that too when it was finished and
there number four as this communication
to the to its base regarding updates is
that acceptable and does this damage the
fallout brand and last which would be
lured brats favorite subject
the media has the media bin on is it a
click baby mentality going wrong brown
like to kick Bethesda while they're down
that kind thing so let's break it back
to topic one this one focus on first the
state of the game you know game engine
was acceptable that launch Lord rap I
need you to set it off first
alright so my my issue with with this
game and and look I was I was I've look
I'll give you a little history me and
Bethesda they sit in my backyard I have
actually colleagues friends at work
there
you know and I you know had tremendous
amount of respect for them as a studio
and was looking toward looking for
Fallout 6 but I think we can trace we
talked about the engine some of the
issues the game has I think you kind of
trace is all about to Todd Howard going
on III and kind of setting maybe another
realistic bar expectation for this game
giving I think you know previous
iterations will fall out and some of the
other games at Bethesda studios and
release I mean even when I don't joke
around our games have bugs you know and
kind of laughed about it I'm like yeah
that's funny it's true you recognize it
but you know maybe that joke joke around
about that's too much because the games
do have I mean it have historically had
bugs and you know I think for me I think
one of the reason why I wasn't as vocal
about the bugs I can fall out for
because everything else in that game
kind of took me pulled my attention in a
different direction there was enough
there to wear either bug you know trying
to find Sean and trying to decide what
fraction I wanted to be and all the
interaction with the NPC's and you know
the choices you make and how those
choices affect the game and everything I
mean all those things kind of you know
where were things that for me at least
as a gamer I was like you know I can
look past some of the performance issues
that this game has now right I go back
to e3 and int on Howard's like you know
we have a all new you know rendering
lightning landscape technology you know
he this allows us to have 16 times more
details you know and I'm thinking okay
this is this is interesting like you
know maybe this is this is a maybe they
made improvements to the engine right
you know and then you know the beta
comes out and the beta is like two weeks
before release and that to me it's not
really a beta it seems more like a demo
I think at that point just pack up the
CDs give me a game of former like we
used to get demos back in the days you
know magazines and popping more xbox's
or playstation whatever you play on
mm-hmm and and then I started reading
like on Reddit some of the issues gamers
were having with this game and then
young a brings up an adjacent Schreyer
that that and that's a whole interesting
dynamic
that's a big one right there connect
that that whole youngin yogig wasn't
necessarily saying like you know he
wasn't being a provocateur and that's
Jason's you know trying to insinuate he
was just pointing out that hey you know
what you know there's some issues in
this game I mean maybe it's time for
Bethesda maybe to look at using a
different injury because the proof is in
the pudding there's issues there's
issues that continue to happen in their
games and you know a lot of those issues
you know I started reading about some of
the bugs that happen or that plague is
gaming there's bugs from fallout 4 that
somehow made their way to fallout 76mm
now I want I want to back you up one
second because you're making some strong
points of rap and I just wanted because
obviously we used the terminology game
engine right and this is a point of
contention especially with a lord Jason
Schreyer now he's seeing it he what he's
saying is that technically it's not that
using that terminology is misguided
because L like a misnomer bassy because
he's saying it's not just a simple
program so basically saying like certain
parts and certain tools are carried
forward but it's not necessarily the
same engine so to speak and he feels
that a lot of us as gamers or
provocateurs are utilizing that
terminology the wrong way what do you
feel about the whole engine thing like
the whole with Bethesda and blaming that
engine on me look man I I'm not a
developer but I can only look at the end
result and historically I can only look
at what what that engine has produced
right you know I know Jason says what
what has that engine produced what has
it produced right now it's video right
now if previous games ahead bugs you
tell me that you're okay
putting $60 you're our own money $60 I'm
getting to that
I know you're missing one you're missing
one mm-hmm what's that anchor Skyrim
okay okay okay lenka hold on was like
less because we were gonna be fair to
brat we gotta let him finish and then we
go right behind but I respect you
interjected on that part what I think
Skyrim was it was a good game it had its
issues the problem is now there's a game
that has significant issues like we
can't like we can like like the the
issues I had with um with um you know
people and I understand like like no
one's there's no one's discounting that
that that Bethesda's make good games
we're talking about this game we're
talking month 2018 mmm you know we're
not talking about 2012 2014 and what
young a is saying is hey look these
issues have existed before mmm
but why are we having these issues six
years later seven years later
mmm paying for that now fair enough
I see I see where you going through and
so that's that's where you are as far as
the state of the engine correct my
bribes will make sure you get your
points often reference that yes okay
cool Lord increments what do you feel in
reference to the Bethesda engine the
state of the game that's all I want to
point you to folks on it at this point
all right so I want to start off with
the two things mm-hmm first off it is
not my job or my privilege to try to
defend Bethesda for bugs or PR stuff
like that okay I can I can't make
excuses for that one cuz I didn't work
on the game and I'm not getting paid
that's not my job which means you may
have the other one too is but for people
who are watching I just want to clarify
so I may have missed this there get
disconnected for a brief minute sure
is anyone actually played the game here
um no I have this is not this is not to
dis this is not to discount this is just
to see if anyone anyone is arguing from
experience or just what people have been
reading online no I'm when it gets to my
turn but no I have not in the game no no
I couldn't hear that was actually you
can't dismiss what's going on beginning
I just wanna see what was argue from
experience or just from what they've
been reading on let me let me answer
your point with this I was planning to
get the game I let me just get to my
point now cuz it kind of leads into what
I was gonna say well he got to me which
was I was planning on getting this game
like literally when I saw it at e3 I'm
like man this game looks fantastic man
this is fallout with friends I want to
pick this up as the review started to
come in and I started to see what the
actual gameplay loop was and in
conjunction with obviously the bugs and
things that nature it didn't appeal to
me so I said you know what I'm gonna
wait and see but for as of right now
with the lack of NPCs kind of similar to
what Brad said you know and there may be
way more importantly was vats I love
that I think that's is one of the
greatest things in Fallout and because
of an online persistent game not having
that in the functionality that I would
like it I knew that
this would not be the game for me so
that was my position on that particular
good okay I will say one thing about
NPCs because you brought it up but I
don't want to feel about this later sure
there are 10 pcs in the game there are
just no human in PCs questrom that's
racist sir when the game came out I
played it for a little bit the issue I
was largely seeing was in terms of how
enemies were handled where in Fallout 4
you would go to one area you kill them
then you would leave the area and they
would reset after maybe like 10 or so in
game days and come back and they'd be
back but it took a lot of time now it's
in this one persistent world they are
always respawning its duty the issue
whenever the game came out and I it was
the first person to say this about this
as I have receipts for that I was first
person on Twitter saying don't jump on
this right now it is not solid yes the
issue was they had all the enemies were
responding so quickly and so you would
have like an event they wanted you to go
through but they could do in a
single-player game like they wanted you
and encounter the certain pack of dogs
mm-hm and once you get out of the vault
and they want you to go over that
portion but you would kill them but they
would reach they would go through the
respawn timer too quickly because other
people are trying to do the same thing
mm-hmm they're jumping in and going
through that same part over and over and
over again so they put they increase the
respawn rate so you'd kill it then
within 5 seconds the body disappears and
then about a minute later the new pack
of dogs spawn that's like [ __ ] oh this
stuff constantly I say that was the
biggest problem I kept seeing it so then
they had all their other issues with
them you had like there was a possum and
I called it Schrodinger's possum because
it was both alive and dead at the same
time it was alive and walking around but
I could loot it like it was dead that
was those were the real awesome those
are the real problems that I saw with
the game now those problems have been
since then I think a lot of it had to do
with just that launch because you wanted
people to go they were gonna be in the
same area constantly and I can I have
much can I ask you when those issues
were resolved how long did it take was
it about - about a week correct was
there about a week yes that's what I was
that I experienced was that it was that
post 40 gig plus patch or was now server
side kind of thing I think that was more
server side because like the the the
paths that they did the 40 gigabyte
patch geez that fixed other problems
that I wasn't particularly experiencing
but other people were saying they get
Rand smoother in certain areas and I I
did not personally see a problem I think
it was more to say they up the respawn
rates and those particular areas because
they want people are gonna be playing
more frequently fair enough
now addressing the engine thing kind of
pissed off cause you took off my Jason
Schreyer point I'm ready for you baby
I'm ready
the thing about engines and there's a
great article also by Jason stride let's
keep in mind - Jason's Schreyer is
probably the most objective point of
view in this he's blacklisted by the
things like black man his crew has no
reason to be defending them whatsoever
like Toki's point very seriously it's
like in the thing about the engine and
attacking the creation engine this is
how but that's the operates they do
three games on one engine they moved to
the next one they had gamebryo for
morrowind they did it for Fallout 3 and
they did it for Fallout New Vegas then
they have the creation engine which they
did for Skyrim fallout 4 no fallout 76
and then they're gonna do the next set
on a new engine like but the thing is
it's the thing about engines and
adjacent rider is a good point about
this is that it doesn't flee yes exactly
it's just a system of programs to make
games and there may be certain things
that you like more than others like
everyone loves Unreal Engine right my
realm is pretty dope mm-hmm they chase
it Unreal Engine is still operating on
the same base framework since 1998 they
just add an extra word an extra letter
should over to it say oh look its new
its new
and they but that's the
tene Lee changes the parts of the engine
and for people to say oh they didn't
change anything it's exactly the same
when we play fallout 4 last night mm-hmm
there's a difference let me ask you this
you broke down the actual technical
style which I'm very impressive do that
but what I gotta ask you this from the
optics right
we as hardcore gamers we know this right
for the most part we understand that
it's a little bit more in depth but how
can you translate that as far as the
frustration of the average gamer when
they don't they things working in a
correct fraction when they see these
things you know kind of broken in the
glitches and stuff like that
we know behind the scenes that it's not
the exact same thing verbatim cut and
pasted right but what are you saying
foot to the to the quality of the game
when people are very dissatisfied this
is a different kind of game than what
people expected and I think there was a
messaging problem when they announced
this game but I think I understand what
they were trying to say and I as someone
who has played the game for about 24
hours now of actual game time I see it
as the game is designed for fallout with
your friends that is how they marketed
the game right and when you are playing
with your friends everything is designed
towards that in right the the vision
comes to life and it's like wow this is
great right the problem comes in that
yes there are bugs but then the question
also comes up is well this is more
financial side of gaming need answered
how do you justify QA testing yeah like
I need you to be good was it acceptable
to you
at launch we got a lot of points I want
to move forward at the point of one
month I found that it was acceptable not
not ideal
well with that man this is like okay as
I knew what it was because this is an
online game like Ark or some other kind
of MMO white structure and there's going
to be problems okay there's going this
is what
for you I know you're up for you just
for clarity you were acceptable with the
condition of the game at launches when
it makes sure I have that quick with the
understanding that it was going to be
fixed later and they were going to be
problems you you are of the Lord dizzy
camp that as it as the ships of the game
being a multiplayer fallout with friends
in your opinion you felt that because
it's not the single-player fallout
experience you wasn't expecting that
level of positive things would because
because I realized that this is an MMO
light right genre okay right are going
to be proud and us I just wanted to
clarify your position Lord added you are
next state of the game engine was
acceptable at launch to you many times
if I came on here and said that this
game is gonna be a dumpster fire long
before not buying the game because they
can't make single-player games without
glitches what makes me think one minutes
that they can make a multiplayer game
without budges right right today you
know we're the ones that that give
Bethesda this power let's be role in
this game came out and it was like the
quality of a fallout on actual Fallout
game or an Elder Scrolls game how it's
always went is the positives far
outweigh the negatives mm-hmm usually
the positives was an immersive world
great story
precise fallout 4 and you know you
really enjoy playing the game this was
different this game sucked overall it
was hard to outweigh when the game
wasn't working half the time you know
how many times in sky I've had textures
met disappear I've had save files
completely deleted so I've fallen to the
mat more times than I count and I still
consider that one of the greatest games
of all time because the positive
experience is always outweigh the
negative everything I see the negative
explain
raises a fallout 76 far away the
positive note that um chief Tommy's
coming at us and he's saying that it's
an action role-playing game it's not an
MMO and um but irrelevant is saying that
he's would anchor that he's an avid more
MMO player and he kept his
experimentations in check what do you
say to that attic Lord from snob where
has nothing to say this game is an MMO
no I don't recall this one has bundy
ever come out and say that the season mm
oh no no anchors actually right they
they refuse to use the term and my
mobile Bungie they used console like
shared shooter kind of a deal they never
commit to the trust it's the same kind
of game just different aspects mm-hmm
like that I see these you can 76 as a
just about the response to a destiny
division like complaining about this
game you just you got a look in the
mirror and that's how you blame this
game was deleting files before now every
forum wants to act like they surprised
it's not working correct
I want to try me real quick cuz for me
it isn't like like I don't like I'm
never gonna sit there and despair at
someone who who likes the game like
anchor you like the game that's awesome
right um I know people that like the
game I know people who hate the game
I don't want to play it anymore because
of the issues you know for me it's about
principalities principles in this mask
put some bodies of this game you know
and and when you bring over bugs from
three years ago and in this game
same old bug right
that's what I want to know saying oh
there's bugs from three years ago just
want there's well the power armor and
there's another one with an infinity
health for some enemies bug I heard that
- yeah I mean yeah you more like let me
address let me address one thing about
that because people wonder talk know
though is that the one you're mentioning
about the the affinity health thing
though those are two different types of
it's the same outcome but two different
types of bugs one in Fallout 4
you would have enemies that were
legendary status and you would shoot
them if you didn't kill them in one shot
they would regain all their health and
mutate that was a that was anything they
don't have that they don't have that in
Fallout 76 and this the problem with
fallout 76 is that you're having the
it's the same kind of outcome but two
different things
what's happening is if that particular
bug just a monk not it's no because on
that one that's always only for I'm
trying to explain to you what happened
it fallout 4 yeah the legendary enemies
whatever you would shoot them that was a
part of the game mechanic they would
come back with that but in Fallout 76
they don't have legendary enemies like
that anymore
so what's happening in that one is it's
an actual bug where it's glitching so
when you would shoot it and you could
kill it in one or two shots
it would regain its health and it would
come back because it was registering
like a like a couple seconds from prior
it is one person explaining because they
would cut they were going up against it
they said it was a mechanic that was
designed to prevent people from just
having opie weapons one-shot enemies
because there's some people who are
walking around who have I or 1:54
already and they're killing like level
like level 60 enemies in one hit don't
forget the fallout 76 beta couldn't be
deleted off my PC bug they said don't
know that's your fault
Jordan you preorder they tried it
the bugs get a service pack update I'm
done my point is it's principality's
like I just can't I don't think we
should reward developers but paying $60
for products aren't that aren't released
finished
that's the agent I have but you freely
should have baked a little bit more you
fellas yeah I mean a beta 2 weeks before
release and then you know people then
you know you the promise of you you know
you're you're gonna be in this game you
know you're not gonna notice that you're
being a you're in a server or something
that effect I don't know that you don't
but but though yeah but you get dropped
from servers people complain about being
dropped for servers on numerous
occasions mmm you know there's the issue
of you know when you when you when you
spawn into a gang you you don't cause
any damage you have to log in log back
out log back in people are reporting
people reporting a list of problems and
it's like yo how can you charge $60 for
a game like this like to me like as
gamers like and it's cool like if you
have fun with it rock out that's cool
but for me it's about principles I can't
I can't sit there and give a developer
$60 and it's for an item that's not
finished what other product or consumer
product that we go out that is
half-baked that we give them our full
retail price for it fair enough fair
enough let me get the rest of the laws
it is because we got like a lot of
concern Lord saw me you have not talked
I am dying for this and then we got King
on deck I know Kings chomping at the bit
comedy from a point of having not played
the game well the issues that I've heard
about and that I've seen I think the the
the main thing for me is that they've
taken they didn't look at this game from
the ground up as a multiplayer game it
felt like they just took the framework
of a single-player fallout and added and
won't be player to it and did it didn't
realize the consequences that would have
in the in the real world when they would
put it out there in the real world then
all these things start coming out in
terms of the engine and how that
functions and I agree to all the
adjacent sorry those engines are
something that are constantly evolving
things they just dis constantly built
upon until they until they decide to
pick everything up and move to
most part but as the games are really
big really mass right and they didn't
really account for everything when you
look at it but this is a game right as
opposed to as opposed to something like
a rockstar game and a GTA a Red Dead
where for an open-world game the amount
of bugs in comparison to like a bethesda
game those games are really polished in
comparison to but that's a game the
thing of potestas because since it's an
RPG that relies on systems that rely on
each other like I'm on the top of the
other what's really tough like yeah eta
games Rock dog and ran Red Dead those
are not RPGs those where they don't have
that many systems to knit it collide
like that so I get that that certain
bugs just continue to keep popping up
let me let me let me cut you for one
second because there's a very strong
point shout-out to a relevant native
shout-out to dizzy and this is the point
I need to ask you solve or as single
player experience gamer this was the one
that's you're not sure miss no that's
your tag right there's nothing madam is
over you're right that is your tag is
the certain level of expectation we have
right and most people coming in we come
from the fallout perspective of what we
want from a Fallout game right are we
wrong for being upset because a lot of
but what I'm hearing out here is that
this is an MMO this is what's expected
of an MMO and we have false expectations
coming in expectedness to work like a
single-player game already feeling that
wait are you how do you feel about some
things to that first of all as in like I
was saying before with the with the
single-player stuff I think the
expectation was when you go into this
game that it's a fallout game and it
doesn't feel like a fallout gaming [ __ ]
it feels like it should not have been in
the Fallout universe um that's what it
like to me like it shouldn't have been
and if it was gonna be in the Fallout
universe they really needed to think
about how that translates to a
multiplayer game as opposed to the
single-player experiences they've been
giving us and I think that's them that's
sort of the mistake they made if you
want to call it that as game has been
out people been playing it now what in
terms of the MMO thing I think if you
look at Elder Scrolls online Elder
Scrolls online is an MMO in the
Elder Scrolls universe that is
traditionally for us meant a
single-player game the Elder Scrolls
online still feels like Elder Scrolls
mm-hmm it still feels like it's very bad
as true yeah I played that game it very
much feels like that yeah it's one of
those things worse okay they took the
time to fill the boot lid fallout that
mean these mixes a bootleg for ya yo
shadow Hansa yeah it felt like they
could have they could have just come out
with a new IP to test this with and not
necessarily besmirch the fallout quest
without quest question what do you mean
it doesn't feel like a Fallout game are
you talking about aesthetic are you
talking about the slow rolling various
watch I want you to clarify your stable
a lot of a lot of work from a lot of the
funding battle is the weirdness of the
human NPCs in addition to the to the
mechanical racism again in in the
structure in Detroit teach you nothing
further not to be there because you
don't want them there not because
they're not there you want them there
but that's that's backtracking there yes
that's favoritism sir cogs PC he got the
NPC robot for this anchor so what do you
say about all missions that are just
basically you listening to a recording
and following the blood from a point B
Point C that was it
talk about that for a minute so the
structure of this game in terms of lore
it's not much else you can do because
it's 20 years after the vault opens and
there are barely any humans out there
there are there are a few humans who are
out there calm and I will not get into
super spoilers but there's something
getting of them just our clarify I get
that they're saying Bethesda use the
Lord to not do anything for the game
like to the level of which fallout 3 and
Fallout New Vegas and fallout 4 had
humans out there there aren't that many
out there anymore mainly because they
haven't a chance to settle the
radiations too steep right now in the
fallout 76 why I've been everyone else
in shelter 76 those are all players
those are all players and there's one
there's one actual non player and it's
the overseer you're trying to find them
that's part of the mission structure
I'll tell you this as somebody who
doesn't really like the multiplayer
stuff the fact the premise of the game
is freakin amazing the fact that that
you're the first vault to open and there
are no humans and they want you to play
with your friends it just felt like the
underlying game they gave you doesn't
support that premise the way it should
mmm that's the issue that people have
besides of whatever the bugs or whatever
so I don't mean you know that's actually
been a common complaint thing a lot of
the reviews yeah yeah it doesn't feel
like the game under underneath supports
that yeah you know and again there's no
permanence to anything another thing
like every time if you Nuka a town it's
nuked for the duration that you're on
that game on that server in that moment
when you come back to and you're in
another server that's all still there
mmm you know and there's something about
permanence in these games and and to
create a sense of being in that world
pretty much sovereign is a cycle I
wanted to say burn you don't want it go
like right dead wanted to be gone once
with me once in one game I sort of
expected as part of the as part of the
series right so and I understand
fully that the it's a different type of
game but they didn't build the
underlying game to support that so I
want to clarify because what I'm hearing
is that we are shaming Bethesda for
trying something new we work we wanted
to say guerilla games Oh Kurla games
didn't want to do that our first person
shooter anymore we're gonna get them
straight to the bushes you know game is
beautiful the story's great the combat
gets boring it's you know it's it's a
it's it's kind of a cookie-cutter
third-person action game
believe me I'm actually with you guys I
haven't I was out here saying friends er
Donna's mediocre as hell horizons err
awards gaming community as a gaming
community we rallied around the gorillas
we said good job you deserve Game of the
Year because we tried something like but
the game was was a game it was a
different at the end of the day the
product that launched was functional
whether you like the game that's a
network word that we just talked about
from a pure fundamental level we have
documentation that can be two to three
pages long of everything that has gone
wrong with the basic fundus of us
everything we can't say that with her on
zero done that's all I've but I want to
get kidding there cuz can you been
patiently about thinking rubbing his
head because anchor is definitely one
hundred-percent hardcore I salute you
sir I salute I just what are you on
anchor Manta
always be on the defensive when it comes
to this I feel like there's like a
special medicine you have to go to the
pharmacy and be like oh I need that I
need that fallout shelter some way to
find that crappy deaf stalker game crap
that you'd be playing and what you know
I lost my horizon zero dawn crashed on
him four times two hours delete leave he
said it was um problem did you guys
experience no helmet I jumped in like
three months later so did anyone
experienced instead picked up Brad did
you I never experienced it but I'm not
this is my first yeah do you have a day
one I don't know I don't know I had
never had any issues okay continue
continue no I'm just saying that you
know you know oh he's right Sam say it's
actually right I would bridge I don't
want to mean catch off Sam's right I'm
looking at a games GameSpot article
talking about huge patch notes back in
March last year right they had passions
but about my question is at the time my
question is is that not even by the
quality game my suggestion is was this a
consistent widespread issue that
multiple gamers were reporting like I'm
hearing like it like isolated incidents
right I'm maybe his specific is I have
not heard I guess unless you couldn't
show me documentation unless you could
show me news reports that multiple
people were in an uproar because their
horizon zero dawn didn't work at launch
that is news to me so I'm not gonna find
that let me know
so anyway continue harm King oh no I was
gonna get the game to play with you
seriously and I told you that that's
when I saw it I was like oh maker don't
play that I think I'm sitting with and
and the idea of it was fantastic I
thought in my head I thought it was
going to be fallout and you have people
in the world and you know they give you
missions and like every other MMO but
they didn't say it was an MMO I don't
know I I think the game was supposed to
be a
to play game they should have made it a
free-to-play game because if they put it
out in this terrible of a state let the
game grow and if you put it out as a
free to play game with stuff that you
can buy to supplement the income for the
game
I think it'll grow and they it could be
better than what it is this way I don't
think the game is going to get a chance
to survive mom I think they put a dead
duck out and everybody's gonna have a
problem with this game that plays it
just because of confirmation bias
they're going in with violence they
hearing the talk and so on something
happens off their goals that's a good
point I wanna I do want to bring that up
later well see for yourself I saw I
don't I don't want to do that I don't
want to get a game going in with
preconceived notions about the game and
any little thing to set you off and then
you just throw it to the sides I don't
know okay so we're gonna jump in alright
so we got that dead mice everyone now
let's get into a bad gate obviously we
know what is going on it has been a
collector's edition we know I came
helmet you know obviously we know that
there was a canvas bag that was
initially reported to become part of
that package shortage of canvas that's
the one thing I do like you know the
games I look at the canvas kills the
game are below this you know obviously
it's it's real sketchy on how it runs
I think don't fix that in all sense I
think this game will be a completely
different game in a year but screwing
over your player base in your fan base
that without and pop 200 on a legendary
collection and giving them a $5
obviously if they're happy $5 of
currency in any form they they all be
saying yeah we did you wrong you know
sent a link really much he said they
aware that a made a statement aware a
small number of users that were
experiencing the horizon zero dawn
crashing before the cinematics so he
said there was a small group of users
that did experience they so put the
article in there so you can see it jobs
synthetic indeed but the fact that they
did that
you know the in we're talking about if
someone comes on a legendary collection
that's your hard hard-core
well then say then going about that
imagine all the people that didn't hit
them up there's probably a bunch of
people that bought that because they're
fans of their their games and they
didn't even reach out because I think
the highlight was that helmet okay I
want to I want to get back into the real
aspect of it which is I get the helmet
part that was definitely the highlight
but the question I want to bring in this
going on on his Twitter street it is
bait and switch you know because
obviously we know what was announced we
know what was told we saw the imagery of
a canvas bag right but then I see when
people started seeing the report start
to come out and people started to
receive the bags it was kind of like a
nylon kind of a cheaply made bag that
was the part of the store I feel like
when it came to that I said I'll take
the Negro books fancy hat with the $5
you know when it came down then that's
the biggest issue of the story because
that's their biggest fans there's a good
chance that those individuals that throw
wrong by that they're not going to go
out and pop 200 on anything on them from
now on
right especially when they came out now
although would have took his email be
like we don't have if you want to go out
and you want to cancel the pre-order we
understand we didn't have enough to
finish that I guarantee you a good 80%
of the people that pre-order does like
okay good that's all they're gonna say
is the helmet
yeah okay then I'm good okay because you
jumped in is it bait and switch in your
opinion and era and then what about the
reward of the 500 Adams as a
compensation which I guess was roughly
$5 us that was pretty much gonna we're
gonna take 80 bucks from you or give you
five back now that's what made it even
worse because that's pretty much like
okay you gave us all this money you have
all this trust in us we're gonna give
you a penny back because we took 200 why
you know and that that bag.look the
quality of that bag looked horrible so
you know I don't blame people who are
being mad I'm actually more upset that
they did that than the game not working
because I don't own the game okay fair
enough so there we got it let's get back
the whole big like you know where you at
with all his that bait-and-switch to you
yes cuz it was advertised as such and
then I mean I think even Game Stop is
still advertising the game is bag for my
mistake and at least for as of 72 hours
I think you know but I also think that
this thing got more traction in the
media too and because of how they
handled it like when the Twitter
response was well you know we just ran
out of materials as you know there's a
shortage of canvas on planet earth and
then there's like well that person who
tweeted that really is the official
Bethesda employee their contract worker
so it's like okay who is controlling the
messaging at Bethesda like what's going
on oh you know what's even worse no it's
even worse than that like like yeah that
the wording of that tweet could have
been done way better oh yeah go ahead
and like inquire here for compensation
and don't tell people what it is no it
was them right afterwards they started
giving out the actual canvas they get
the hi Louie knapsacks wait wait wait no
you know the official people yes
spending hard-earned cash
they they saw one thing in the picture
he received something else me for people
that didn't purchase their went there
got the bags that dudes painful yes boss
tickets like The Fan Fest bag we got
like they got the best hotness
[Laughter]
communications there's no communication
I mean all of this stuff sort of just
snowball at the same time so it's just
it just looks super bad but it like the
whole point is it had been it would have
been one thing if they advertised those
bags and and those bags just weren't it
they never needed those bags right they
made those bags if nobody got that and
those bags were never created it that
was just for the advertisement and then
at least you can blanket it somehow but
you can't believe you I think it might
have been but I don't know this is not I
don't know but it might have been
something where they had more pre-orders
and they expected mm-hmm and they
weren't prepared whoa they were like got
the good bags for the canvas bags but
then like oh then the whole thing
overloaded it all these people
pre-ordering that edition because they
bid the pre-orders were up at e3 for
this but hmm yeah let me let me get Sam
he's got he's got a good point y'all we
had we have to can't miss this and so I
was gonna jump onto Sam honest he's
saying that a journalist fight such as
Jeff grub has already said that the
influence the influence her bag issue is
completely different and that basically
he's saying the game rant article was
incorrect and they're responsible
journalism so the whole fact that these
are kind of like separate issues it
wasn't like you know BAM now we gonna
send this okay
they got the Gucci thank you but it's
optics at this point but it's optics and
bad timing but the product that they got
resembles what was advertised for the
foot it even remotely resembles that and
what you get and pay for doesn't
resemble what that pay then it's fair
for anyone to assumes like they decided
to give our hot stuff to them like the
real question is do you think this is
hurting Bethesda's image over I which is
that which is part of the question which
I think I know when when Youngblood
comes out next year when Wolfenstein
comes out when the next Elvis Krause
comes out when stars darling that's
never happened never happened to me no
but there's a great that's a great
analogy that Steve Jobs put out there
bang when he was alive
trouble was the term that he had it was
what's called a a brand deposit mm-hm so
what they're talking about is the the
example he used was that whatever a
company comes out with a new product
that that's received very well or they
have a good PR moment they make it
deposit into the brand bank and so they
they have this balance go up and
eventually buy but if something bad
happens like a product fails or there's
a there's a recall or something that
that's a brand withdrawal from the bank
but what the thing is the higher that
brand deposit is the higher that brand
balances is as long as that's high
enough bad things can happen and people
are more willing to write out the
[ __ ] right I mean that's the right
now they have a high brand balance if
you have high value of them but they're
so they may times are used only one sees
a positive balance and I swear I'm not
lying that's what I'm saying is that
balance is going down nobody that does
they have this bed you know
I think it only heard you say anything
everything I heard was completely
negative about what went down and I
swear they must have put a lot of money
in your bank positive outlook to
everything I you just said those are not
the same bags the influence had
different bags these do I know but what
what I'm getting that King is that like
okay I know three different people
personally who got that power armor
Edition they didn't even notice it was a
different bag all they wanted was the
helmet but when they noticed it how did
they feel that it wasn't what was
advertised now did they notice it like
they notice they're like oh okay like
they didn't feel really really I could I
can I'll give you a gamer tag of someone
who just realized that leading they told
me two days ago that they realize like
oh it was supposing you can this for you
can you do one but bad breath oh no it's
gonna say you know I you know I'm sure
there's people that probably were like
yeah you know whatever the bag you're
not wanted the helmet you know I'm
probably didn't care I don't think
anchors you know what he's saying isn't
true about the folks that he knows that
they picked up the collector's edition
to me it goes back to goes back to
something principalities in this game
and there's ethics and regardless of
whether or not you cared about the nine
levels to canvas it's the fact that they
advertise this in a way and then changed
it and then let the consumers know yeah
the way anchorman is talking I just got
one I just want one favor from you
anchorman why don't you turn that camera
on and show me that back because I know
you have it
no you was I saw reddit post yesterday
where someone was saying did the the
tagging it was there was a title with
something like but that's the line I I
feel like I was deceived and the tag was
like I was told I was gonna get a suit
of power armor with it it doesn't work
but I want to touch on something King
King brought up earlier the podcast and
this happens every single year
especially in a crowded like the crowded
holiday season but this is what you said
like it the first point where people
feel the need to justify their purchases
and not only the people like who buy
into it and they innovate they have that
income and I'll talk about that latest
like we see with consoles all the time
and it was specifically like people are
usually using fallout 76 as a scapegoat
this year to justify their other game
purchases mm-hmm I want to get every I
want to get internet you hold that
thought for something cuz it's literally
no that's the last point we'll wrap
yourself basically which is the media
aspect right and like you said you know
there's a lot going on there's a lot of
negativity going on around the game and
the question which is lured brats
favorite subject is demeaning there we
go so has the media been unfair to this
game has it been a clique Brady
mentality has it been a piling on is it
a kicking butt des des finally when they
down because for the most part like I
will agree with that in this sense that
like but des does um Bank
as far as the preparation and reputation
bank was always high they were below
right so when when their games came out
and maybe had a minor flaw here the
scope of the rest of the game was so
amazing almost like how me and addict
we're having issues with red dance-off
maybe we were married you guys right it
was like red dad is so amazing are you
talking about them on the the red day
juice yeah yes right but desert had that
level of clout in that level of
reputation at Bank that a command is
saying that it would and this is the
ride this is the first time that we've
ever seen this from it that is so I'm
gonna give it to Rob rap one it's a
really what rap honest like do you feel
the media is being unfair to fallout 76
all right before I get to the media
question I do want to say one thing I
don't I think the most important thing
now moving forward is what if desert
does with this game and and much like
you know hello and no man sky they can
turn this thing around I mean there's
there's there's definitely examples of
games that as president yeah that's
precedent for that and and I hope they
do I I don't want to see Bethesda you
know this rune or tarnished image
because at the end of the day you know
like hey man brought up you know some
previous game Skyrim they they have and
I think this is this is why the why
we're seeing this because going to my
question or the question about the media
because of the the type of game
experiences that they provided us over
the last you know decade or so decade
plus I mean I go back to you Daggerfall
more when fallout 3 fallout 4
you know they provide us with tremendous
hours of great game playing fun in these
immersive worlds and you know I remember
what it was like to find Shaun I'm like
I found Shah I was still like I got
choked up I'm not gonna like I choked up
cuz I friend Jon I did you know and I'm
all out three was amazing - oh my like
tremendous memories great game yeah yeah
your father it took place in DC Metro
and oh yeah in the subway fax or
advertising in the subway and so for me
to go to fallout 3 and go to Dupont
Circle
Circle metro station I'm like wow wow
this has this is great Bethesda thank
you they're paying homage to your
backyard and where you guys are from but
so I think with the media and I hear
people say all the meat is piling all
now the hey train you may have some
people out there look on Twitter that
probably jumping on the hate bandwagon
because they just want to troll and and
be haters but at the end of the day I
think that the the reason why we this is
such a big story it's because it's
pathetic because of their pedigree and
you would never expect to see this game
and the byproduct of this release you
wouldn't expect to see some of the
issues and in the dropping of the ball
with the collector's edition and and
everything else that's kind of its like
the snowball you know the snowball keeps
getting bigger and bigger for them and
it's like they they can't catch a break
and I think it's because you know they
they have they didn't execute well in
this game and anytime you have a big
company like this who has such a great
reputation of course the media's gonna
talk about this because you're like well
how does this happen but let me let me
ask you this and we know this is a very
sensitive issue for you Lord Ram do you
feel that people are taking advantage
clickbait t misinformation do you feel
that is is it a result of people trying
to drive traffic to their sites because
this is hot news right now versus the
game is just the joke they call the you
know the bad news that just keeps on
giving so it's free I mean I think
unfortunate the bad news that keeps on
giving but yeah I mean obviously you
know media sites are the covers because
it's the hot topic and it's gonna drive
it's gonna drive your traffic and look
at the other day you know we could
disagree with you know clickbait but you
know this is what this is what they do
it we could Beit isn't anything new age
didn't they should do it and you know if
you remember back to the the days of egm
and the magazine covers and who's gonna
win the console wars you know it's gonna
be PlayStation Dreamcast I mean those
are the kind of things that we see at
the newsstand that would get our
attention at all we gotta we gotta read
that article mm-hmm you know but I I
don't think it's a it's a media thing of
you know we're just gonna you know we're
gonna beat this and we're gonna beat up
a Faysal because you know we hate them
or
how dare they do this I think it's just
a hot topic right now and look man it's
just it's it's it why not what I mean
these media sites have to make money and
I get that there's a business side to
this and course that gets natural
they're gonna want to drive traffic and
they're gonna cover the story that's the
hottest story right now and I finish out
the phones in the chat he's like but
there's the line that's why the people
are pissed it's that simple they out
here selling hot dog water far too long
it's time to give but as the the e a
treatment and force them to shout out to
the meme on Twitter
did you just see the dark force mean it
got you got the poverty and then I got
the young Anakin Skywalker yes yes
you're learning now like alternate
effects good alright so there is a
contingency here of yes people are using
this for clickbait I mean the fact that
we have Jason Schreyer straight up
calling things fake news hmm is pretty
crazy
was it they there was the article that
came out that said Oh elder scrolls and
starfield are gonna be using the same
engine with no graphical upgrade like
they that is clickbait and Jesus trial
went out of his way to say this is
clickbait in fake news he said this on
reset era like he is going out of this
and that I find that very telling that
you have a dude who's blacklisted by
Bethesda but is committed to telling the
truth hmm
and to give you that journalistic
integrity that that signals something to
me okay so you feel you feel that there
is a click benjamin town you you feel
that people are at Harling on i
definitely agree that people are piling
on for other things like only so the the
big thing the big news things law firm
is investigating bethesda for policies
that that's already been dropped and
that particular company has a history of
doing that kind of thing anyway mmm is
they they just jump on whatever the
hyatt the biggest thing and they they
want to get that attention
it was sound like you when I talk about
talking about Phil I swear I see it I
see it I can see why people like I see
it because I see it you are completely
100 percent drinking the kool-aid and I
am with you brother because exactly I am
with Phil so I see with it and I've not
get it wrong they must have did some
serious but like 1200 that's the way I
do it I want to talk about the store a
little later if we can because this is
really getting out of control
yeah we had a rap this time they messed
up are they in the bushes like da hell
to the no mmm all right no they're not
that bad this fiasco
yes is it click baby yes a lot of people
do it because a lot of people want those
likes a lot of people want that look and
so to put up a negative power arm
because they see it the traffic will be
driven that way if you put a negative
article towards this game mm-hmm they
they will do that so like positive
articles thoughts God's award
oh my god of war stuff like that net
drives traffic so when somebody puts up
something negative about Xbox Microsoft
you know they they go any click on today
so I understand what you're saying and I
do believe that they're piling onto the
game is the game probably as bad as
people saying I don't believe so because
there's a lot of people that's actually
playing the game but people are trying
to justify their purchase let's say they
pre-orders of Red Dead mm-hmm right and
it had the choice out of pre-ordering
ready
man they got red dead and red haha I
told you crap and if you listen to
Attica Attica tell you is not as good as
you're saying right in the sense
somebody is always gonna have a problem
with something but yeah I believe that
they piling on the game but I also
believe that the game is half-baked and
it should have been cooked and put out
in a proper form later on not in this
back year oh stop I need some we gotta
fly through these time you got one more
part about this thing I just think yeah
the game is not it's not ready it's just
not it's just it maybe it should be
something else like King said before
free-to-play game let people like you
know change the structure of it in a way
that that makes it monetizable in a way
that isn't you know it isn't nasty and
you know and and build a build build a
multiplayer game mm-hmm and that's it I
mean being on there I think I'm excited
to see where this game go I hope they
continue to work on and improve on it I
mean you see the change is Final Fantasy
14 right you know came back out and it
was a totally different thing no man sky
when it came out came out you know
mm-hmm so obviously it's not be on the
wrong path right could you do that
um I need addict these in the bushes
little bit what I want to say something
about elaborating on who know so also by
the way if you go to check on the Xbox
story follows 36 number two behind black
ops poor side even though Red Dead
Redemption had that online re lunch that
what I wanted to get out like this is
the whole thing about the whole snowball
thing I actually don't blame the media
for it and this okay I blame the YouTube
gaming community
so you're on Jason's frier side actually
will you believe in this case yes
the provocateurs like you have people
because that in Kingwood King was saying
is totally right
you have people who if you try to say
something positive it does not nearly
this is the same kind of response to
something negative
absolutely yes no you have you have
people who jump on let's hate on this
because it's a popular thing to hate on
right now and it's hard to be like okay
I want to be the positive for this
version like when I started doing
YouTube and everybody was hating on Xbox
everybody was hating on it I said no I'm
gonna I'm gonna like Xbox I'm good
that's I like the product I'm gonna I'm
gonna say I like it and I focus on that
side of things and but other people like
they they just want to jump on what the
what the next big hate thing is because
they can get some clicks on it like I I
have one guy i watch i hear i can't
remember inside YouTube ding off the top
of my head at least but he he doesn't
comics focus comics and movies but as
soon as Paula said he was getting a
negative attention he jumped on board
like you don't follow let's do this be
fun mmm my thing is like this the thing
is with this this product things thing
about where games come out and one game
has to be the fall guy every year like
it doesn't matter how good that game is
it just this one he's one but there's
the slaps elderly woman anchor she had
it coming honestly you know I'm so bad
he said you can't cabbage control this
game is not what was avatar you stop it
stop it
they are going you know you and I got a
question you didn't see the one where he
said that Bethesda burned down an
orphanage and anchor said
she said what was that burn down an
orphanage and then you say well those
kids are kind of terrible but let me
channel my Ebenezer Scrooge that let's
decrease the surplus population we got
we got we I hate because you cuz we got
one last point with this and I don't
want if gays no one's talked about it
and that's that griefing is that's the
correct way to say against griefing yes
okay grieving I was sorry
died because it just happened you know
and pretty much in fall 76 there was a
group that was calling themselves the
gay eliminators of the queers
let me PC yes people to have cross play
with oh my gosh let me finish out the
fans burger to Jen so oh yes I'm pretty
much this was on pc correct and pretty
much guys named AJ he reported to
Podesta how do you report these people
they were grieving them and apparently
the way fallout 76 works it prevents
players from killing attacking each
other if there's no neutral desire to
fight but no one in four hours
invincible right so if peaceful players
don't want to fight they can still take
damage will just be slower so these guys
continue to harass this gentleman came
this proximity chat so it's like oh
pretty much what went on and then
obviously we know most online games they
have you know that built-in report
option no for people they don't really
have that you know I'm saying this is
their first it's on pathetic net release
so there's no reporting system on the
software system and play out on our Xbox
in PlayStation even though but there's
it doesn't have
place on Xbox and places we all know you
can use Xbox Live because that to report
a player based on their tag PSN
yadda-yadda-yadda
and I'm Sam well apparently it's not
accessible this client that they have
it's not clearly advertised so the tweet
went to the community manager in
Bethesda's defense you know saying a day
where they found they got ahold of the
people who are involved they have now
banned those accounts permanently from
his game yeah because obviously they
don't want people players to be attacked
most games have in-game reporting
features right but this does not so
basically the point of this whole thing
is as a result of things like this and
the systems that are not in place like
do you also think this is a problem do
you also think that this should have
been implemented at launch especially
with a game with the scope of proximity
chat and interacting with other people
that there should have been something in
place let's start with King and then
let's go to budget oh gee like two
podcasts ago I missed the races 360 back
in the days when I jump in a rule with
nothing but white supremacist I made
them my friends it was like lifelong
friends like how did he know okay he
died let's say he's not join me like
what what did he want to sleep people
are not
he wanted to play in his own space it's
a multiplayer game oh because that rated
these dudes got together it was like
let's have some fun in this boring game
they made us a wild name it's funny it's
funny as hell they pointed to do that
was like yo he's such-and-such
let's go clear right so these days they
probably was jumping around them hit
them and it was telling them while I'm
standing next to them please
so we're gonna take you out so I think
it is utterly hilarious that happened I
would have let you guys beat me I'm
gonna be let's go find somebody else I'm
pretty sure he's by the team they could
have waiting on another dude they could
really have fun I think it was having
fun and that's mission banning people
accounts because it was outside having
fun you intended them to have fun why
you banding these dudes
no you should've just gave more
reprimands she just say yo stop doing it
you know don't do that because defending
the alt-right or xbox in those rules
with me with those white supremacist and
you love every minute of stop it right
now
Lord breath I need you on the griefing
brief right a lot but yeah griefing
system you know [ __ ] that have been in
play how do you feel about that whole
situations rant
that's right
I mean I kind of get what he saying they
did advertise you know create your own
experience better and why they couldn't
implement the grieving system well we
know why would a bug down there just a
minute I'm just joking I'm joking now
they should have implemented that in the
game but you know I don't like I you
know and I remember King I finally be I
think he was I think he was even worse
on the like beta days at Xbox Live the
OG xbox yeah we used to get racist ha
I mean people be like you know died
ninja die and you hit some while out
mess now even you could be a part of it
right and you can just go along and have
a good time when your call of duty King
some of these guys were angry man they
like to play his game
ok no ok if they're children that's
where the line is drawn ok child and
this is why game should be
age-appropriate right if you're putting
a child my kids
well my son doesn't play online because
he won't be playing with somebody and
call the duty to run up in one of those
rooms with like that don't you
understand so the game shouldn't we
should allow adults to play with kids
right right that's how I feel so you got
you don't want your ESRB right now yes
I'll be there that can go left though
like that can really go left that's
that's the small tip iceberg for that
you know it can really go left will you
have adults playing around and moves
with kids now if you're gonna have kids
playing rules with kids now that you can
have a good time if we have adults
playing rule with adults that's good
that day we're doing that to a child oh
man you can't take a ribbon that's your
business
okay I need you on this er all right
but I will say I miss those old college
city search-and-destroy lobbies yours
leave a force for I love that oh my god
like yeah yeah it wasn't rough yeah it
was rough and tumble kind of stuff in
there but man the passion you have when
you kill somebody in your gut sitting
out in the lobbyists watching if you get
a match finish man that was the worst
was Jeff metal people be playing Death
Note over there speaking oh yeah I just
went through you to those people like I
do I want to hear your rage was telling
me that I don't care what room they ran
in I've never heard nobody say those
days of the bad days those were the good
days I have I have one moment I
remembered I'll get to the top in a
minute you're playing black ops 2 Search
and Destroy we I was playing it like I
was just out of got a class when I was
in college and I remember coming back in
playing search-and-destroy with a buddy
of mine man we got in the lobby
no ants I died first because I was
eating something I was like I'm just
only here just to listen in some paint
someone came in the lobby
they just started singing my girl by the
temptations know better was that other
people started joining in Wow and by the
end of the match everyone's in the same
lobby singing the song all together he
was dying I couldn't believe that
happened
it's moment it did what has happened is
I believe we talked about this last hour
with the introduction of party chat
unfortunately everyone now stays in
their own circle yeah okay now they're
no longer forced to interact cause there
number braaap that's how we met new
friends yeah a lot of my Xbox Live
friends I met on the original Xbox
online because we just happen to be you
know in Mecca salt or Rainbow six you
know oh hey what's your name you know
you play pretty good let's you know what
you gave it a list you know old man came
back in my day we enjoyed races I'll do
what you say Brad because again that's
the part I miss and I do hear this
saying - because it's like when you
played that Co D surgeon destroyer with
sinister eyes to play their sinister and
it said party chat disabled you gotta
talk to who you with and I think it
encourages that interaction you made
those friends and now let's be honest we
don't really make new friends good so
the whole griefing thing yeah I don't
even know if it's true honestly I know
but my experience has been you always
have someone who comes up and they say
their side of the story you recorded
it's not oh you recorded okay recording
okay then we're fine it's not my little
things like I used to do these master I
used to do the X Box Ambassador Program
and I remember people could complain to
me about oh this person said something
mean to me and I'm like shouldn't be
playing call of duty by like you're 16
where you played a great game
sorry my thing is at least with this
scenario I mean should they have
reporting
them yeah yeah yeah they should but at
the same time I'm like sounds like a PC
problem don't care about PC gamers Xbox
and PlayStation guys remember I mean
even if you play another game you see
the in the game itself we'll have the
report feature so that you don't mean
oh yes earlier I went to check while you
were talking that up on fallout 76 you
could pull the people in your recent
playlist or now you pull them up you
click on it shows you the profiles they
did but that's it on Herot feature
obviously an Xbox Live and PSN are doing
that on a packet right if you I played
destiny I can actually go to him in game
and say hey report him to Bungie he did
it you know I'm saying you can have the
tool that's what I'm trying to say so
from a tools perspective it's something
that they need but that's my thing like
that
that kind of stuff on any online game no
matter what game it is it's gonna happen
my you you have people who just love the
outrage stuff but there's no way to
prevent that from happening
all you could do is report it as the
best thing you can do solve it then we
got a ramp-up man maybe taking so many
elves on this game
they needed a W so the fact they pounced
on it as fast as they did it that's
their W that I know we got to make sure
every take care this quickly I don't
care who if it's lie I don't care what
it is because do it get outta here er is
right on this way I mean we'll finish it
this time we went along obviously but um
yeah I mean that's pretty much out here
what everyone's saying I'm with you guys
um it's a tough one it's like I said
ultimately I was planning on buying this
game and then with each controversy and
each you know fog and stuff like that
just basic core mechanics are just not
there for me so for me you know I think
I will say this though I'm very vocal
I'm happy that people are vocal only
from the standpoint that because but
does they had that high reputation what
happened
turn the camera on a babysitting to the
rule surrounded by campus bank that the
piling on as people are call actually I
think they needed the watershed moment I
think they needed in humbling you know
I'm saying at the end of the day you
know this is something that kind of
gotten away from the mugs are kind of
unacceptable you know and definitely
certain core aspects of the game are
amazing
but it's not to the standard that people
expect so ultimately I think they're
gonna come out good with this long term
I think similar to Bunji Bunji had the
same mistake with d2 and in the launch
and they pissed off the hardcore
community they pissed them off and it
took until forsaken for them to get it
right the question though is will they
be able to get it right during the
iteration of Fallout 76 or whatever the
next iteration of Fallout is that's my
only thing well that's what I got only
anybody else got anything before we move
off of a fallout sent me six men all
right
solve game war leaks what's leaking
apparently nothing so let me let me uh
shout out Rocksteady real quick or
folding half of my topic like in saying
that um they're basically they're not
working on you're not working on
Superman and bait whatever they were
working on so I mean they may be trying
their best to sort of throw people off
and maybe they do announce something who
knows but as of now they're saying 100%
they're not gonna be announcing anything
so the other interesting tidbit that
isn't a leak the announcement that
obsidian will be announcing their new
sci-fi RPG at-at the game of wars and
the speculation around that which is
crazy to me but not necessarily is that
it could be something in the vein of the
blast of the Bioshock universe and
please fire super interesting the reason
that people are speculating that it
could be in the bioshock universe
is the fact that the game is being
published by private division private
division is the publishing arm of
take-two that deals with indie Studios
right so um through the private division
David Ava
they've actually published Kerbal space
program they're working with Patrice the
Slayer
the creator of Assassin's Creed on his
game um so an obsidian on this upcoming
sci-fi game so the interesting thing
about it is that again because this take
to bioshock has been dormant for quite
some time and the two little tidbits of
sort of game art that have come out
indicate something sort of in that vein
that weird sort of dystopian vain kind
of fall out like kind of a Bioshock like
so what do you guys think man I'm super
interested by this I'm just and also
what's the art setting look like it sort
of looks like it's so it's future but it
has like there's one that shows like a
bunch of different like like kind of
like medicinal things that you could use
potentially in this world and it's stuff
that seems like like the stimulants you
would use like in a Bioshock game stuff
like that um and it looks like it's it's
kind of that future retro look where you
like you're talking about the future
versus the 1930s something like that so
it's like a like a like a like a funky
looking Raygun and stuff like that so
it's like this this weird future where
it's probably really dystopian and in
but you're not advertising it as such so
that's why I say like the fallout vibe
where it's like there's something wrong
with this future there's something is
not quite right so give like a link take
a look at this moment please what do you
guys think about this what do you what
do you think it's an Xbox exclusive
which I
don't think it is right that's my main
thing I'll just jump in right quick I
believe yeah I mean I'm interested I'm
very very very interested I just want to
be clear I just want to ask you like
this is pre Microsoft acquisition
obsidian game correct
bidding before yeah right so we got to
be clear so that the fanboys understand
oh it's that kind of be like this is
most likely a bowtie plat game I just
want to be clear that right yeah and all
I give what it is it's interesting like
this could be huge if it is a game of
the bioshock universe it can be like and
if it you know if it lives up to the
hype of old bioshock bioshock 1 dlc of
Bioshock 2 if it lives up to that level
of of of game and the fact that again
obsidian with the RPG pedigree it could
take the game in a number of different
directions because Bioshock isn't a pure
RPG um we've already seen what obsidian
is done with you know Fallout New Vegas
with alpha Protocol with those type of
systems mm-hmm to take that expertise
into a sci-fi setting that could
potentially be linked to the Bioshock
universe it's super exciting because
these guys this anybody who's gonna take
up the mantle of a Bioshock an RPG
studio like an obsidian is it's perfect
it's really perfect to elevate that that
whole formula and to change it up it's
perfect are you excited about this man
talk to anyone who'd like playing it's
endemic yellow waits on the podcast
buddy no you don't want anything
anything with obsidians name on it I'm
hype I'm hiked and I can't wait to see
you know it especially when you talk
about possible Bioshock stay give answer
button know anything in the bioshock
universe man I
it might look my eyes were wide open
they have my attention I think to to
cognitive point I think do you think is
probably multi plateau because this is
something that was in you guys say in
works before they deal with Microsoft
yeah yeah it's probably multiply but
it's not a big deal to me you know it's
not yeah people upset about it and you
know to me you know what if it's a good
game I'm excited for it so I can't wait
to uh to see this Lord anchorman you
know look at the pictures now I look at
the pictures now yeah I I could don't I
could totally see how this would be a
bio Sonic game based based on this
concept art alone do you I don't know if
you guys know this but like right next
to fallout Bioshock is that that's
serious for me like it's it's right
there it's they are they often go back
and forth right number one slot so it's
ya know just to hear that another
Bioshock game is in the works what they
they say this every other year or so and
maybe I really hope is true really hope
it's true I'm not I had ideas from where
they could take it I mean this kind of
supports that I'm not entirely positive
by me just concept art so I don't really
know for certain no I wanted them to go
more of a space route yeah do kind of
like do pray but not pray but instead no
there's a couple of things but the thing
about a Bioshock one is what philosophy
are they gonna use what's the setting
like that that that's what Bioshock
succeeds no would you be disappointed if
they came out and it is something in the
bio shocking words but it is a you know
three-quarter over-the-top isometric RPG
as opposed to what we expect from
Bioshock which is the first-person
action oriented I would not have a
profit was like a third-person kind of
game I don't think I would have a
problem with that necessarily if it is
like a top-down like you know old-school
fallout kind of stuff I might have a
problem with that except really
[Music]
that would be a huge deploy departure
from what made Bioshock appealing like
that that would be a big change
nobody six confirmed you gotta be king
oh no finished oh yeah dude based on
this concept art this looks like they're
going for space like I'm looking I'm
looking at it really close right now
like I'm zooming on individual parts
like not just the style but it's more
like a Jules Verne kind of vibe mm-hmm
they're shooting for but not just that
like they know the title says it's not
the best choice it's the spacers choice
and then they have a little plate a
little spaceship insignia on the side
mm-hmm like that that looks pretty close
Anka let me ask you does the Fonz in to
check stirring up trouble look man he
said that's terrible news this is for
you and Saul this is terrible news that
this is not um for Microsoft and a fan
base that it's not exclusive it just
gives them slim hope that anything
coming out soon be exclusive for them
what say you anchorman what say you saw
you two are the most excited I don't
have a problem with being not exclusive
because it is what you're gonna do it I
hear so here's a position and I think
every Xbox fanboys gonna have going on
after its yes PlayStation fans please
buy the game bankroll our future titles
no problem with it if it if it's a
Bioshock game and it's not exclusive
obviously I'm gonna probably not but
it's a new IP and it's not exclusive and
it still falls under that that that
whatever take to and private division
have with them that would bother me
somewhat because that would indicate
that IP does not belong to Microsoft
which is weird I mean it would have to
be some some weird contractual stuff
there but the if it is a brand new IP I
would I would hope that Microsoft gobble
that up as well so you know if its BIOS
on it
there's always the possibility that it
could just be like okay this is the
first game if there's sequel potential I
mean Microsoft can either buy that or
like that what would make it worse
like in a scenario where the game comes
out and it's amazing that you find out
the sequel is exclusive yeah yeah people
freaked out because it would be almost
like a Tomb Raider situation right we're
ready
except permanent yeah exactly exactly
King do you care you'll link one this
one oh we don't drop drop in how salty
like Bernie just like yes you want to
get it for free dough and we gotta pay a
fee no they don't know I was going to
ask you about that how you thought up of
G with sleep they basically announced
that oh yeah it's go to game pass oh you
guys go to PlayStation 2 but he says
coming out next month what a joy they
don't get that is up as a free game
critic you were totally right you went
one step further because you know people
like my god he said not now is $1
so funny though that makes it really
funny because that is Microsoft
especially this generation has learned
how to steal thunder they learn on every
on every announcement like it's been
crazy again this year hmm I didn't even
hear that mob she was coming to
PlayStation until like a week after
right like it just recently just a
couple days ago and when I heard it was
coming a game passed that day I heard
that I was like okay yeah whatever don't
care very much true man
just want to fly through we got last - I
mean addicts gone but I'm gonna give it
to King um King you want to get into
that Xbox 1x revenue sir Oh No but you
know everybody know Matt piscatella
because everybody salty on that right
now becomes an alloy become Lord with
Matt you tell us sit there and tell you
PlayStation is selling this and
PlayStation has done this
the world is holding them up on a throne
fact you are the savior but as soon as
he says box is something they drop a
minute walk past okay so apparently Xbox
one X is doing phenomenal and Xbox is
showing the most growth of all consoles
so my thing is this xbox 1x is that
growth because they have I think it's
over isn't it one hundred and some odd
games because shout out to coast
Eastwood
he did a whole show chat : x yes on how
the Xbox one X is definitely living up
to the promise right right
oh the 4k revolution right very silently
a lot of these games is being a 4k 1/8
of a 4k dynamic and they're actually
reaching and hitting that peak where the
multi flats are playing better there man
is that movement funding Microsoft
Office because
the X is actually selling a phenomenal
rate right let me jump in um this is a
fantastic topic I'm glad you brought it
because at the end of the day shout the
boss will he said PS fanboys with
yelling fake news that bad I felt bad
cuz Lord piscatella you know he is privy
to this information right braaap like
here these information that we don't out
grant it if you truly want to question
North piscatella if you truly feel that
he is playing favoritism if he is
getting under the table deals you to can
buy the NPD News it's for purchase it's
like you can get the information so I
just found that quite interesting
armless says this you know obviously
Xbox one exhales I'm an Xbox one sales
shown that they have grown that through
out of the three major high are hardware
platforms in the US the end the Xbox one
X is doing phenomenal and it seemed to
strike a chord with a lot of people yet
I'm saying especially with the console
fanboys and all I will say is this like
it's like you know how I use the analogy
King it's like like the music business
right you know PlayStation for example
it's like they're going Dimond right
they're doing so phenomenal in record
sales right and it to me it's like and
we know that they are the console leader
however when Microsoft announced the
Xbox one X it was announced at $500
everybody said let's be honest and even
I was questioning yo I don't know about
this mid generation console refresh I
don't know about $500 we all said that
in his podcast at least at one point we
were concerned right and on top of that
we were also concerned like you know
they really light on exclusives right so
we had all these factors going in to
this situation and to hear this news
it's just really amazing what it showed
me is like I'll use the music business
analogy which is like yeah they're going
Diamond PlayStation is doing something
outrageous but it's like the equivalent
of Xbox one going gold but then when the
axe come out they go platinum so they're
still doing well and they're showing
more gross than and then the others in
that regard so I just thought it was
interested you know say I'm very curious
about why dudes are in the
feelings when there's positive Xbox but
that biscuit Ella I think that's very
interesting so I'll bring it back to the
table man like what do you guys feel
Brad like what do you feel inking saw
what you were yet with this whole xbox
1x revenue is it fake news no I mean
it's not faking use anyone and anyone
who's coming at map this could tell
leave the guy alone I mean he's not a
console warrior be he's a he's a
professional I mean he's been on ILP
he's been on braaap a couple times and
you know he's a student of the game I
mean he is getting these numbers from
reliable resources and he's just
reporting industry trends that's that's
his job and no one should come after him
for that that's just nonsense I I saw
some of the stuff he would all Microsoft
is paying you you know I you know I
think like you guys I was kind of you
know no offense and how well this thing
would sell because I wonder our price
point mid gen refresh but I think in and
look I this is just my estimation he
right I think that probably the core
Xbox consumer was probably because of
the the Xbox one probably a little more
ready to upgrade so I think I think that
went and I look I was I was wondering I
was like alright the X is coming up
getting rid of my VCR Xbox one Xbox got
the hot mixtape with the album is trash
[Laughter]
that's foul you know what that is a
great analogy though seriously this is
this is good for the industry like
people like not we should be angry about
this is so I'm so happy for Microsoft
they're doing well because I think this
is good for the industry what we want to
see competition we want Sony Microsoft
to push each other because we're benefit
recognizes how many systems how many
companies have we seen die like in our
time how many companies are lying why we
seemed I started looking at companies
because I was putting their names on the
side of my
the arcade cabinet I got coming and I
seen data he's tiny
I seen companies that we actually were
just looking forward today games and
these guys are getting salty because
they said that the console we're dying
it's over so if the console space dies
right think about it in this and in this
thing if the console space dies mm-hmm
Microsoft has another Avenue to go to
they go right to the PC correct all
right
Sony doesn't have another avenue to go
to the console space die they pretty
much die there Nintendo has another
space to go to they go to the handheld
and dip off mm-hmm so the fact that
everybody is selling this is the highest
beautiful the switches selling the
PlayStation a hundred million let's go
baby let's go fax you know the Xbox they
not telling you the numbers but the Sony
News will always keep turning around 35
million a bid on 35 million for four
years shut up right but they selling
phenomenal so that means obviously that
numbers a little bit different bro but
why wouldn't you be happy because your
chosen media your chosen genre your
chosen entertainment sector is growing
and it's becoming part of everybody's
culture how many gamers you see now so
why are why are they afraid of the sales
of Microsoft why are they salty winners
it's very interesting I agree is
validation yeah a lot of people I guess
off jumping it's completely validation
is that it's that argument that you know
you have to validate that your plastic
is better than my plastic and it's just
it you you don't want to see it and
again I this behavior in grown men just
really blows me away but that's what it
is it's just validate validating your
purchase as opposed to the one you chose
not to now you know the horse in the
race
I mean I don't really all it is this is
my card would you dumbass king of statue
shows so I gotta hold boxes of stays
King they coming for they coming for
boxes I don't think they ship statues Oh
surprise is it really no surprise to me
that they they're selling this well
they're really the only ones if you
think about it constantly pushing their
marketing on you to you in different
ways like whatever pass something new
coming to game press they're constantly
pushing ways for you to engage with them
ecosystem would it be the console would
be the PC if you look at a PlayStation
PlayStation feel they generally don't
have to do that like the automatic
bundle right started pushing the
narrative again but beyond that they
don't necessarily push the narrative
themselves same with Nintendo Nintendo
sort of doesn't push anything and so now
like you have the Pokemon bundle you
have the Smash bundle they really put in
the name Microsoft I feel the ones that
throughout the entire year they're
constantly telling you game past get
this bundle get that final bundle so
it's all you know at some point that's
oh that's gonna pay off I feel you can
you got you you feel this is a not fake
news with the revenue I mean again
what's the point we mad about like what
what incentive does a man have to lie
about that kind of thing always always
look at the motivation behind people
that's why we were talking earlier like
the whole thing to Jesus friar like
dudes blacklist that he has no reason to
be defending Bethesda at all like this
no point whatsoever for that Fiske
atella the V defending Microsoft are
coming up with a lie there's no reason
to it absolutely I would agree all right
that was the Attic laugh I'll just talk
his topic and I'll just say my point be
out here you pretty much the NCP
Nintendo creators program
for those that don't know that
didn't end those little things as far as
you know monetizing allowing them to
monetize videos and content they have
gotten rid of it which is a huge deal
you are and now you know not to worry
about being flagged I don't necessarily
so on basically adding one to say you
know what do you guys think about that
it is the timing interesting based on
the fact we know Pokemon is how we know
um smash so I'm gonna give it to solve
because you know smash especially switch
getting in a building I want your people
see it smash anywhere anyway hello
pokemon speaks for itself but it never
hurts to have more new eyes on it so
facts so whatever whatever the impetus
was for this it's a good thing they need
to stop foolishness let people make
videos and praise your products as they
want to do let them do that make a
little money off it though the lower
braaap what do you feel about the
content creator the channel getting
eliminated think it's about time I mean
for the life be I could never understand
why Nintendo was against free
advertising correct Raiders do it free
advertising for your product why not why
not let them have at it I mean I and you
you build a community around that I mean
that's that's where the future is me I
think how much we talked about twitch or
if you were on Brad one time Cognito
we're talking about knows key we're
talking about remember the thing with
Jason Schreyer the future of journalism
how youtubers are kind of becoming or
becoming at the forefront yes reporting
news and and and you know just this
digital world I mean that's it makes
sense I mean this is they need to do
this because it's a it's again like I
said it's a form of free advertising and
now you start building that digital
community you know and it's it is a
word-of-mouth like it used to be like
when we were growing up yeah just--we're
the mouth or social media now right so
what a bribe do you think it was just
more of a fear thing than why they
didn't allow it any what then cut their
games to be berating you know youtubers
can be tough sometimes when they don't
like them yeah I mean I think it's
probably is fear is probably them being
very protective as Nintendo has like
Disney with their IP
but you know I think somebody woke up
some wait a minute you know anyway and
with the timing of Smash Bros Smash
Brothers perfect game perfect game to
put out their own twitch and YouTube and
build a community of that you know yeah
absolutely now what you man I want you
anchor what do you feel about timing man
I clearly it was plan to do it now
now the online service is going out now
that you have the just everyone in
general just to be excited bout smash
and Pokemon like a just that that's the
timing of it but at the same time I'm
looking at it as like I don't know why
the Intendant was worried about their
games ever going through that because
they're they've been way more gameplay
focused and story or anything else like
they they've always been way more
focused on that like I like if it was
like telltale or Sony or someone like
that where it's a heavy story experience
and once you do the story once you're
done mm-hm like I could understand that
I could understand them having a stance
against it but no like this doesn't make
any sense for them yeah boss bolshoy DP
gaming in 2018
Jonathan green Nintendo did it because
the PS classic dropped they wasn't ready
for that PS 480p competition discover
YouTube until 6 months ago you can you
good you think it's good bad in all my
videos so I cannot be flag now yeah I
can just jumping I can see gameplay Oh
Barry y'all gonna do Barry I'm Mario
caught I'm with you all types I must I'm
uh making a Nintendo dedicated channel
that would be hilarious yeah it's gonna
be good no playing this is this combat
wanted to highlight their favorite games
and their favorite games as a Nintendo
games and for a long time they weren't
able to do that and being that they
lifted this band up because they
actually liked destroying that program
people are walking away from the program
there wasn't being profitable so they
destroyed it and in doing that that the
benefit of it was allowing youtubers
that actually put that content out
because what it was doing was impeding
the content to be showed because they
wanted it first on a platform in
something like that like the first right
to view and all this other stuff so the
wording was wrong and once dad got
abolished it allowed for the content to
be shown now for everybody so it's just
only a good thing more contour for
everybody lords I mean I do think the
timing is interesting Lord Soph I think
that of those an issue stop concerns
earlier this year and you know remember
this which is kind of banking on that
back loaded of their biggest software at
the end of the year so to me what
further what way to get the heyday of
the switch because Hades King on this I
have not played my switch all year we
all know that the MPD doubles obediently
but
but Zelda push the Mario push all right
and Mario Cart whatever one of my kids
blender right that's just that's not an
exclusive so that was just you know
rehashed but um the game that they did
with the the rabbits the right
so those three games validated my switch
for me I want and for you right now is
it's not there for the rest of the
animal chrono if you care by animal well
when people try to tell me the best game
you got right now as LA noire listen and
pokeballs out anger you wanna be about
is not the first Pokemon game just all
over again people don't know that now
for you guys right now
I could wear does it go be for meat oh
no no joke no joke right
my brother was talking about getting the
switch for his girlfriend to play I was
this close to say like this is your
Christmas gift just take mine
I don't even care about smash anymore I
don't even care get outta here
throughout I'll people this week in
regards to the continued negative press
that fallout 76 has received regarding
Metacritic reviews game functionality
and the collectors edition bed do you
date media outlets have unfairly adopted
a pile-on mentality in regards to the
game the choices are a yes
fallout 76 is an easy target for
clickbait journalism and those who have
not played the game again you like that
one
be don't know if I can see where RC is
no fallout 76 getting quality and
Bethesda themselves are to blame or see
I don't care unless my collectors bag
don't have that premium canvas down the
aisle people at the end when it goes up
Lord breath and Lord acre and absolute
pleasure to have you both back in the
world that man's been with you long been
great to have you wake and to find
people find you think I'm gonna have a
little bit of a long out show here wow I
just want to give woo I want to give a
shout four horsemen of gaming and I just
want to say I love coming on your
podcast I love what you guys are doing
you guys are one of the best podcasts
that I listen to just keep up the great
work guys a be spiritual a be this is I
love it every Sunday is great and I just
keep doing your thing
so thank you tada it's an order
seriously for me amongst the world
coming for you and shout out to brat
podcast fantastic podcast shout of the
team be money slo-mo black stamp mom man
Ford say you don't say Eric Jackson it's
a great group of guys these guys have a
great podcast please plug the basement
radio arcade podcaster
yeah absolutely uh you know if you want
to follow me on Twitter you can at
braaap underscore podcast and if you go
on youtube you can find us at the
basement radio ok podcast give us you
know if you haven't sub sub and hit that
Bell button to get notifications when we
come alive and when new content comes up
and we go live every Wednesday night at
9 p.m. Eastern Standard Time so come
check us out and I also want to say
anchorman was a pleasure podcasting with
me I haven't done a podcast with you and
quite a long time man so it's a great
you know great talking video games with
you again and love your passion man let
me past for gaming so faxing and shout
out to both y'all for being respectful
of being on both sides letting everybody
finish that was great to see and show
that everybody can have different
viewpoints and still come together and
enjoy these great games Lord anchorman
first of all salute because you
like one of our original friends to the
realm you showed us the light you can
say you let people know about the ILP so
slew for always coming through and also
salute for riding with God Howard all
the way to the finish you are a national
treasure sir I had to get you all this
casted thank you for coming through last
minute quick and five people find you
what you got going on you guys we find
me on Twitter and everything else that
anchorman v2 my it's a multiverse show
is on our own channel I just saw
multi-verse show we also have our own
Twitter account this multiplier show as
well we go live at 8 p.m. on Monday
nights Eastern Time well yeah thanks
know now shout to Jonathan beasts and
Lord Jason Schreyer aka anchorman was 5
[Laughter]
so we got our out of Antony sauce Lord
saw waked around people yeah first up
big shout out to the Lord rappin Lord
anchorman are you guys are not your
guests you guys are IOP family is from
the very beginning hasn't been super
supportive of us and you're not guests
well and I just want to say thanks
thanks to everybody out there which is
from my family and of course my
anniversary thank you so much I
appreciate that
oh and I hope you guys like the the the
new and improved sound after we've been
up I love our cast audio so we lit a
fire under us we all got our yetis
Sampson it's so you got that that's
right you got that preview you know say
the rest of us got yetis you gonna
preview but a salute the RDX and those
guys we were meeting Kingdom on them
this week and they Davis gave us
constructive criticism they love our
show they want to take to level and
salute to the patreon because without
you guys this stuff couldn't happen so
yeah thank you for dealing with our
audio
prior I saw they were dealing with us
yeah oh yeah you guys kept hopefully
playing some red dead this week I ain't
get to touch anything last week so
hopefully get back to some Red Dead but
you guys can find me on Twitter Lords of
IOP retweeting - my fingers fall off and
then if I'm on Xbox Live and PSN BX
Auburn no Lord King the cab is bad it's
funny like I got like little stories
with everybody I got a little story with
anchor bookbag member de Cali oh that's
my dude miss committee three be honest
with you yeah I miss him and he has
always been super supportive always a
hidden that he can lend and you know
when I when I was talking he I have the
same hair for him he can talk to me at
any time so that's like his family
me and Brad got one story - oh and I'm
trying to get him back in the game since
the game was fixed we played the game
when the game was all broken as the next
play we don't play the game when is good
going on this show and like I said
they're family you know sovereign said
it you know best like they are families
it's totally different than that uh we
are real people like we really like
reach out to people we really like
connect with people like I'm trying to
get breath to go with us to eat we learn
yes and that's a that's a real thing
like we got space in the house bro come
on space yeah so you know that's the
thing all right um for me Kos the box is
for relevant don't like them boxes son-
native bro see I don't get little
statues that come inside those little
giggles PVC craps you see them right
there right
well if thousand other statues watch
your mouth watch your suit
oh that's for Kos all right genius
statues is coming I know you see the
promo of it
combat talk you can catch me there but
also um we got other stuff that's
cooking if you looked at them shirts
those churches up and I really want you
to go check them out rep your Lords
rapping alone crazy oh I hope you love
the new camera angle that's the full K
jump off right there logic check the new
joint that just came out and then that
right there you see that ring that's
also iron Lords efficient oh yeah you
tell us to step it up that's our chance
for spawn they get up off their canvas
like the Undertaker
thank you for giving the constructive
criticism so that you better know yeah
I'm the same here man look fantastic
show again shout the egg man shout out
to brat man this was so fun is his
family like more soft saying and like I
say man it's always good to creek
connect with fan because just feel like
an extended episode we just that's
chilling so um yeah man we got that go
arm you already know the audio is gonna
go up and later shout the more come on
so we get that going
also I got a hit what's up J Fonzarelli
definitely hit it it's a special car
that's all coming the 29th of December
is a podcast all right who's not just a
regular combat talk that you're gonna go
to youtube and check that out it's low
it's gonna be an actual panel Oh we'll
be tweeting that out J Fonzarelli myself
laura Cognito we got all meds Lord meds
you know saying off and obviously native
man oh yeah we're going to have that we
gonna link up with fawns it's gonna be
lit in I don't want to spoil their fawns
cuz we got a very very special
professional guest but I don't want to
spoil that yet until that you know is
confirmed you know I'm saying so we'll
keep that tight for right now Fonz but
yeh stay tuned to that it could be very
special or combat talk yeah that's
combat talk with the kings the Kings
Laurel you know yeah so like I said you
only and all that stuff will go up um
obviously please check out that combat
King is out here killing it please
salute the stream team y'all jump
initially even as a second it really
means the left we're very close to
twitch affiliate status so please if you
see stream team and you see l-boogie if
you see snarled or you see Lord MJ you
see Lord de la Pole
just jumping it if we get three people
in there we're very thankful we're so
close to getting twitch affiliate status
so please do that
look how about so we'll have the audio
up also flashpoint 41 with ebon test is
up fantastic episode talked about black
armory that's coming from the Destiny
hardcore and there's a spoiler cast at
the end after Tuesday's run for the
hills at the end that we warned you
multiple jobs that at the end if you
don't want to know certain things you
know leave all that though well yeah my
shout out to my bro all upon test that
is up I'm gonna put the last link for
these shirts that is the go game
Conqueror 1 and I will put the last one
which would be the actual sastra Thomas
and then you can get that on the way out
and I'm staying real quick but I solve
do you got anything on the patreon thing
before we roll out no no patron stuff
everybody Congrats everybody who want
congrats to our gleam winner I'll get
all that info out to you by either later
today or tomorrow get all that stuff out
to you guys so congrats everyone and
like I said like come January there will
be some changes but there's no point in
talking about that now we're just right
figure everything out anything we'll
talk in January obviously and all last
but not least there is an Ireland
discord we will get that information to
you it's gonna be Lords of gaming dotnet
so it's really popping in there please
we're on disk or we're getting it pop
and check us out over there and I will
try to get that information you guys
good we've gone along everybody enjoyed
their Sunday if anybody think anything
else nope alright we out here please
please